pretty much. Humans are going to do what humans are going to
do. Britney, Simon, enjoy her. Good night, USA. For ever. Now,
if he was a 10-year-old, we have a problem. But if the girls
were 13 plus, who cares? Move on. It got worse. It got worse.
It got worse. It actually got worse. I didn't think it could
get worse, but it got worse, >> dude. What the >> Wait.
And the problem is like they were traffic as well.
>> Has opened. >> Oh no.
Yo, W. Big W. >> No,
not Lolly mindset again. This guy's everywhere. I do kind of
respect the hustle. This guy's like decided that I'm just going
to go and tell the whatever like hate mob, whatever angry people
there are on the internet. I'm going to go tell them that the
law is on their side and then they're going to watch my videos
and they're going to pay me a bunch of money and I'm going to
make a bunch of money. By the time anybody knows what's actually
going to happen, I'm off. I'm on the next controversy, boys.
I'm out. He's a bandit
apparently. So, if you guys are unaware, apparently there's another
allegation that was posted today about Pirate Software. The like
the lyric wolf person posted it on their website. So, let's uh
let's check out let's check it out. Let's see what's here. Okay,
you guys ready for the Pirate Software content? All right, you
guys ready? February 7th, 2021,
X consented to anonymously share their experience with Thor.
X met Thor through Howler, a furry dating app looking for companionship
as a furry game dev.
A furry dating app, guys. No way. >> A furry dating app.
Awesome. Howler? I've never heard of Howler before. Is that real?
Howler. Howler article on Wik Fur. Okay. Can you not with the
detection? Whatever. Verify you're a human. Don't make me do
a thing. Okay, here we go. Howler article on Wik Fur. Uh, Howler
was a furry dating app similar to mainstream app Grinder that
relies on user location to find other furries around the user.
Howler allowed users to set up a very complete profile and join
groups related to events they're attending, personal and artistic
interests and kinks they identify with and then filter users
according to these. It also featured a chat and a like system
that allows users to let someone know they like the profile and
eventually break the ice. Cool. Despite X setting clear boundaries,
explicitly stating they did not want any activity, Thor repeatedly
ignored these wishes. Thor insisted on penetrative with X, who
clearly communicated their refusal. He would force himself onto
X and dry hump them. When X pushed tried to push him away, Thor
would forcefully push himself onto them. This would continue
until Thor ejaculated. God damn it. God damn it. I didn't realize
this would be a review. It is. It is. All of it's here. Kind
of up. The website is making furries verify they are humans.
Okay. A weird opinion, but all right. All right. Thor insist.
Oh. When X expresses their discomfort at the situation, stating
it was not okay, Thor responds with, you know, you liked it.
Okay. That's That's crazy. Screenshots show X talking about these
events right after they happened on June 16th, 2024. Screenshots
show X being com comforted by a friend saying it's okay to confront
Thor about this assault. These are screenshots of Thor reflecting
on this incident. We have anything else here? These are screenshots.
There must be There are screenshots. Okay, we have to scroll.
Hold on. I'm going to try scrolling to the bottom because some
notes about this conversation. Sometimes this person like um
Oh, no. It seems to all go in the right order. on previous pages,
this person didn't post things in like a good order and it was
like kind of up. So, I just want to check and make sure that
wasn't the case here. But, it seems like this is all laid out
in order this time. So, good to know. Okay. Ex's experience with
Thor. This was made or sorry, this was during co or just postco
era. This was during the co or just postco error era. We had
met on a furry dating app called Howler. At the time, I had just
wanted to know any another furry gamedev friend. I had no idea
who he was, what game he made, or how big he was on the internet.
I do not follow streamers or content creators. Here, I'll move
this over just a little more so it's not quite as cut off. He
had told me at the time he was going through depression from
a divorce. I do not know if this was true, but this is what he
was. This is what he was telling me. I wanted to lend him an
ear and invited him over. It was strictly on a platonic basis,
talking about gamedev and light cuddling at most. First awkward
sign was that he was unwilling to wear shoes outside. despite
me asking him to. He just told me that he doesn't wear shoes
outside. No,
he's one of those people. Oh my god, dude. Oh, I'm suddenly blasted
to the past. Okay, I think I watched I think I watched like an
outdoor survival show where somebody did this. This isn't from
a movie, right? It was real reality TV. Like there's an outdoor
>> Reban Ruben donated $3. Just took 12 mg of melatonin.
Let the countdown begin. Here's three bucks. Okay. Thank you
very much. Thank you, Reuben. Ruben, I appreciate it, buddy.
Thank you. Thank you. Let the countdown begin. 12 milligrams.
That's high, isn't it? That's like a lot. The Anyway. All right.
Uh, I'm going to keep reading here. Okay. First awkward sign
was that he was unwearing to unwilling to wear shoes outside
despite me asking him to. He just told me he doesn't wear shoes
outside. This led to him this led to him tracking dirt and mud
in my car and home, which was already disrespectful to me, but
I chocked it up to him being awkward. Afterwards, he continued
talking to me about his divorce and life problems and then spent
a few hours ranting to me about Diablo builds and how big he
was as a streamer. I wasn't particularly interested. Dude, how
big was he in 2000 in 2021? On June 16th, 2024, screenshots show
X being comforted by a friend saying it's okay to confront Thora.
Wait, is this on February 7th, 2021? that they met. I'm not getting
a solid timeline now. It is, dude. Selenome.
Uh, Pirate Software. On, let's pull it back. 2021. How big was
he? 18. I got to go to 2021. It's like here to here. Like here.
He was like a 100 viewer streamer. He was like a 100 viewer streamer
at the time. Like a 100 viewers on Twitch. Oh, come on. Okay,
I'll stop telling people to harm themselves. I'll never do it
again. Wait. Hate speech. What? >> Oh, you're cooked. Oh,
hey there, JCO. We hope this message finds you well. >> Yeah,
I know. Can I I'm going to review it. I'm not trying to I'm totally
I'll totally disavow whatever this was. Okay, we're going to
have DG's mass reporting. Cool. I've done this for a while. >> Uh
Archangel, don't ever come back. You're a loser. Oh yeah, it's
the Archandriel guy. Okay, that guy's never coming back. That
guy's never coming back ever in a million years. that I I know
what I said. That guy's never coming back in a million years,
so it was fine. Oh, one second. Kenny, can you uh can you pick
this up? He's a 100 viewer streamer and
>> he was just talking about his Diablo
>> Okay. I wasn't particularly interested, but but again,
as a young furry game dev, recently moved to Seattle, I just
wanted a similar friend. When we started hanging out in my room,
wait, Jesus Christ. When we started hanging out in my room is
where things got weird. Despite me explicitly telling him I did
not want to have oh god or any in on my bed, he kept insisting
on doing things. Eventually, it got to the point where I was
pushing him away or telling him to stop, but he seemed to to
pretend not to hear. And with him being larger than me, it wasn't
exactly easy to push him off, but he continued to okay. After
it it was all done, I lectured him saying that I had told him
repeatedly not to do that. Luckily, I'm pretty thick skinned
when it comes to casual. But if I were anyone else, that could
have been a traumatic experience. His reply was simply, "You
know, you liked it." To which I rolled my eyes in disgust. At
that point, I pretty much said, "I'm taking you home." And even
as I was taking him home, he begged me to take him to the grocery
store to pick things up. Frustrated, I reluctantly did so and
just figured this would be the last time I ever interacted with
this person. Afterwards, neither of us messaged each other on
Telegram anymore. And he >> Hold on. Hold on. Let me summarize
what you just read. Uh,
sorry. I just Nothing. Sorry, I cut you off. Go ahead. You deleted
his Oh, cuz we're here >> now. My bed smells like a lot
of [__] Jesus Christ. He went a little too ham. Thor
came on your bed. Yeah, ZZ. He also didn't wear shoes. What?
Like he like just straight up he came over without shoes. Lol.
Very eccentric person. Br. Sorry. Can you keep going for two
more seconds? I'll be right back. >> Okay. I pretty much
blocked it all out of my mind. I wasn't particularly hurt. I
just thought, "Wow, that was surreal. I can't believe someone
like that exists." For authenticity's sake, I can also tell you
I confided in many other indie game devs in Seattle. This story,
and they believe me, and have always known Thor to be kind of
shady. I had no intention of coming out with my story. I didn't
care for attention, but it did weigh on my conscience because
I do believe Thor should not be allowed to abuse any anyone else
further. I had zero idea that he was a big entity on the internet
until someone some game awards showed him show
I'm actually I'm actually black so bad. I some game a war show
showed him. This is when I sort of realized maybe I should confront
Thor. We're in similar gamedev circles. I see his name everywhere.
And beyond that, I did not want to see further harm done to someone
else. On June 16, 2024, screenshots show X being being comforted
by a friend saying it's okay to confront Thor about the sexual
assault. It feels so bad, dude. I kept I keep playing that night
in my head trying to find some good in him. But whenever I do
this, it's like nope. even without the fact he ignored my boundaries.
He was also just kind of general like he came into my house no
shoes ignore most of the things I said to said to talk to talk
about himself immediately wanted to
despite me telling him no multiple times during the time I was
having a terrible nerf kept pushing himself on me and I was pushing
him off and when I told him that he shouldn't have done should
have done that he said you know you liked it and somehow at the
end I felt so petically bad for the guy he somehow convinced
me to drive him to drive him to groceries and I can't help but
process it as I can't believe >> I'm by the way. Sorry,
I was replying to >> I can't believe someone that awkward
exists, but then he it's like, hey, he was kind of awful, like
real bad. >> Is this the same thing? Yeah, it is the same
thing. Okay, the whole thing. These are pictures of the conversation
I had with him. He deleted his messages literally only a day
or two after we had them and has not messaged me since. So, this
should all be this all be this person talking to Pirate Software
then. Need to talk when you have the chance. Well, well, I'm
not going to sugarcoat it, but our last interactions left me
feeling really uncomfortable to put it lightly, but I wanted
to talk to you about it if you remember me before making any
judgments. Is there a reason we never talked about uh talked
again after that? I guess I just want to know how much you remember.
I didn't want to bring up something 2 years later just to be
spiteful or anything. Oh, this is just them messaging. Oh, so
Thor did message them back. He deleted messages literally only
year or two after we had them. He's not me. Oh, I guess this
person was getting responded to. Okay. So, 2 years later, 2 years
and 4 months later. Yeah. Okay. 2 years and 4 months later, they
message here. Oh, well, I'm not going to sugar coat it, but our
last interactions left me feeling really uncomfortable, to put
it lightly, but I wanted to talk to you about it. If you remember
uh me before making any judgments, is there any reason we never
talked again after that? I guess I just want to know how much
you remember. I didn't want to bring up something 2 years later
just to be spiteful or anything, so I apologize if I come off
that way. To be real, I kind of didn't want to think about about
it much, but it's become somewhat hard not to see you around
in my circles nowadays. Dude, the way these people type with
the run-on sentences, it's so stupid. >> That's just crazy.
>> Hold on. Is this Is this guy having like a breakdown
in chat? Is he like What is going on here? >> He can't.
>> I He's like trying to join the Discord. >> He
can't join. >> Yeah, if he can't join, I've unbanned his
right. His all unbanned. >> He like had an alt that he
joined with that he can't >> put your name in chat. What
are you >> Yeah, put your put your Discord name in chat.
No, I'm banned. >> Yeah, put your name. Maybe he has like
>> Your It's your job. It's your job to unban him, Kenny.
Okay, I'm reading this >> Well, unban him. Oh, okay. Well,
it's easy's job to unban him then. Okay. Do you want to bring
uh see my circles nowadays? We could talk as you have time. Uh
as you have time. There is no rush, but at the very least, knowing
you are sorry is a better thought than none. I was going through
a lot at the time. That infection I told you about when we were
meeting ended up being an undiagnosed chronic condition. So,
in a way, I didn't really have a lot of mental energy to deal
with it one way or another. Okay. Hold on. This is going to be
10:46 p.m. on the 16th. I don't know if I'm going I got to be
going right. Right. Yeah. Yeah. Go right. Yeah. Yeah. Go right.
Okay. Um I was going through a lot at the time. That infection
I told you about uh ended up being a chronic condition. As much
as it would have been nice to genuinely feel like you were empathizing
with my boundaries, it is hard to blame you for assuming I wouldn't
want to talk. That said, as long as you kind of understand why
I was upset about things, that would go a long way to making
me feel closure on the subject. I don't really want to bother
you beyond what that especially if things could be amicable between
us. specifically very vividly. I remember the line, you know,
you liked it and that really just felt inappropriate and it would
have been just nice to hear you say more uh something more conscient
even just something like but seriously if you didn't I'm sorry
I want you to tell me. Sorry, I just got another I was making
sure I didn't get another email. Okay, boundaries like that are
really important and at the time I was just happy to meet another
gamedev friend and was even willing to be helpful and drive you
around when you asked. That's pretty much all I'm asking. If
some lines are blur, uh, if some lines are blurred, there should
be effort to make them clear and I felt I was trying to give
verbal and physical indication of those. So to hear, you know,
why you liked it kind of kind of messed with me for a bit. So
please, I am not trying to vilify you or anything. Just genuinely
giving my opinion. When I say I'm just I'm genuinely trying to
give you my opinion on how it should have been handled. I am
being sincere in that it would be in that it would not be good
if you felt it would not be good if you felt like this was an
acceptable thing to do to someone else in the future or at least
knowing that you cared enough to think about how that would have
felt for me. I'm just giving you exactly how I felt about that
situation and I'm hoping you'd understand why I'd feel that way.
I'm not sure why that would be wrong. And I'm not trying to coersse
or a specific statement out of you. You give me my you give my
genuine advice for the future. just give you my genuine advice
for the future. That that line you had that that line you had
said was inappropriate to me after what had happened and something
you could have said instead. Okay. I get why you would delete
your messages, but it still feels pretty to me. If I was out
to slander your reputation, I would have even I wouldn't have
even tried talking to you. So, this is a I'm not sure when the
messages were deleted here. Okay, here we go. All right. Jesus,
this is a lot of stuff. Regardless, I've said what I need to
say. Whether you want to take my words to heart is up to you.
I was just hopeful for a more empathetical response. No one wants
to be in the position I'm in. It's a lose-lose situation. It's
hard for me to talk about it. And nowhere did I request for you
to make a specific statement. I'm not trying to make you feel
it was that way. Feel it. I'm not trying to make it feel that
way. And again, if things aren't clear, being able to clear it
up would give me personally sort of give me personally closure.
Oh, the way these people write is just like impossible to follow
to me. I thought I was making it clear through my words and physical
actions that certain things were hard limits. Cuddling was fine.
It was the fact that on our first meeting, it went beyond that
despite me asking it not to. I am actually purposely being vague
about details because I don't want you to feel threatened by
this conversation. Again, blurred lines happen, but to me, what
happened after the blurred lines is important. I feel like I
was being too. I genuinely did not want you to feel bad after
everything that happened. I felt really bad if it was a blow
to you emotionally, but I had to process things, too. And I was
and still am going through some crazy [__] in life.
When our Telegram history was gone, I had no idea what to think
beyond maybe that you did feel awful about everything. And but
part of me in my head started thinking, "Okay, so maybe he's
just feeling great about using that twink and getting away with
it." Oh boy. >> Can I DM you again? >> Not like we
talked about the details of what happened much after that night,
so it felt really not to vent it out. I understand. And that
is why I hope to clarify what felt wrong to me. Not to make you
feel bad or vilify you, just for personal closure and to help
you empathize with where I'm coming from. I didn't think I would
either, but So, he's clearly responding a little bit. And this
person's talking back. I didn't think I would either, but being
a game dev in Seattle, your name pops up in pretty much all my
circles, and it felt bad and weight on my mind for different
reasons. I kept going back and forth whether to reach out or
try to resolve things, both for my personal peace and also just
so I'd stop having that reaction. But I felt awful about it for
many reasons. Like you thought you might see me me as someone
trying to ruin you or something. So of course I struggled with
doing it for quite a while. I really don't want you to feel that
way. And I am sorry. I'm not sure how to ease that thought. But
genuinely I feel terrible if I ruined anybody. Being able to
talk openly about this does help uh sorry anybody being able
to talk openly about this does help ease the thought that you
were just using me for reasons. And at least I get to clarify
what exactly went wrong for me. Uh thank you so much for talking
to me. I'm sorry to scare you genuinely. Just knowing that you
also feel like it was a bad situation does come from me a lot.
I really would prefer things if things were amicable. I really
would prefer things were amicable. That's what they said. Okay.
It's okay. I understand why it would feel really bad in your
position. Really. Sorry if I led you on. I was feeling out of
things, of course. Or was feeling out things, of course. That's
why I was on Howler at all. I didn't mean to hard reject you,
and I'm sorry if that hurt. I probably would have talked to you
about these things eventually if we had kept talking. I was going
through a lot of chronic pain stuff that probably made me seem
distant to a lot of people. Ah, I'm sorry, but thank you for
clarifying that for me. Again, I'm still open to being amicable,
but you absolutely do not have to feel the need to be friends
or anything. I'm just glad we could clear things up. It seems
like things were fine. This Perry guy is unbanned from everything.
He's just having like a mental break in the chat. He's like having
a breakdown. is whatever this this guy additional messages images
with Thor's messages. Oh, what? Oh, what the why would you put
Why would they have all of their own messages and now they're
like, "Oh, here's stuff with Thor's messages back. We need to
talk when you have the chance about this. Seems very ominous.
Well, I'm not going to sugarcoat it. Um, our last interactions
left me feeling really uncomfortable to put it lightly. Wanted
to talk to you before making any judgments. Yep, I remember.
Sorry if I made you feel uncomfortable. I cut contact once you
made it clear that things were really negative between us. I
think it was communicated poorly from my side at the time, but
I didn't feel like I had a better way to do so. Legitimately
felt it would be just a blip or something. Blip of something
you no longer cared about. Going through a lot at the time, blah
blah blah blah blah. Yep. I totally understand. I overstepped
at the time and misunderstood the situation. Oh well. I mean,
seems like he's taking responsibility. Uh, this is starting to
feel a bit like enttrapment. If there's something you would like
to discuss outside of trying to get me to say a specific phrase,
or is there something you trying to get me to discuss outside
of saying a specific phrase? specific phrase. When I say I'm
genuinely trying to give you my opinion on how it should have
been handled, I'm being sincere and that it would not be good
if you felt like it was an acceptable thing to do to someone
else in the future or at least knowing that you cared enough
to think about it about how that would have felt to me. I'm not
sure what you were asking for in this interaction. It just feels
like you're demanding me to say things. Okay. So Thor was like,
"Oh, it was uncomfortable." But then he sort of wheeled it back
and had not much else going on. Okay. Okay. All right. Um, dude.
Okay. Like I'm It seems like this person did feel that the interaction
went quite badly, right? And you should do it this way. When
is this? This is in 2024. So this is two years later. This is
a little bit quite a bit later. Okay. H story idea again on the
internet. Doesn't game awards showed him. Man, this is like uh
I was posting the video of me trying to join, but I was told
to delete my cash so I'm adding that into the video. Dude, this
guy is having a rough one. I don't know how hard it is to join
a Discord. It's like not that hard. He's very much struggling.
Yeah. So anyway, it sounds like I need I need screenshots showing
So we have the contemporaneous evidence that he came during this,
right? But I need some screenshots showing that like this person
provided boundaries or that they think it was like non-consensual
here. Right. Right. This is like talking about the interaction,
but this doesn't actually specify that anything wrong happened.
So, I get that that in 2024 they feel like it was, you know,
non-consensual, but I would like to see some contemporaneous
evidence that that in 2021 they felt like it was non-consensual,
right? Okay. So, this is Thor over on the dating app or whatever.
Let's see. So, fighting games I'm terrible at outside of the
old school Neo Geos. However, anime tunes, any kind of big thing.
So, them having conversation on this app, pictures of Mulavius
fig tree. I'd say probably the biggest outcome or the biggest
element of this, right? In my opinion, is just more and more
proof getting piled on that this guy is in fact an actual furry,
right? He is a furry. He's tried to get out of it, right? He's
trying to get out of it. He's tried to say, "No, no, no, no,
no. That's not me. I'm not Mavius's fig tree." But he totally
is. Hold on. Oh, this Sorry. This guy is uh actually probably
too schizophrenic to being on stream. I am being sent other messages.
He's sent. Probably can't have this guy around. Unfortunate.
Too much. Too much. Too much. Too much. I know. I know. I know.
I know. I know.
Um, if he can figure out the Discord, he could maybe come on.
But he's just like a weirdo. He's like a giga weirdo. Was that
an owl? No, it's me moving my my mic arm up and down. That's
it. This is my mic arm moving up and down. Yeah, if he joins
the Discord pretty quick, I'll I'll pull him on maybe. But I
think he's just like Dude, he's like too much. No, surely he
can figure out the Discord, right? He's not farming attention
in the chat. He'll figure out the Discord pretty quickly, you
would think. Anyway, a note from X. It would be good to make
a post saying something about how your post has inspired others
to come forward. At least for me, that's how I feel. I really
hate to see you harassed over what I think is legit a legitimately
to or was a legitimately toxic relationship, especially knowing
that Thor's behavior hasn't improved whatsoever. The way he deleted
his messages, he deletes his messages just to play the victim
and twist the story is gross as hell. Is a recreation of the
conversation. Some notes about the conversation. 11:30, I get
why you would delete your messages. Refers Thor deleting his
Telegram messages a with X after the incident. A recollection
of Thor's Discord messages after 11:16 p.m. He basically deflected
and said that he was emotionally hurt and figured I wanted nothing
to do with them. Okay, dude. This is nothing. This is just nothing,
unfortunately. Who's this? Queen live with 116 viewers. What's
up, Queefers? Hello. Hello. What is up? Come on in. I don't This
is like nothing. Unfortunately, it's like nothing until we can
see like evidence basically that this person thought it was non-consensual
back then or like it's nothing as in there's nothing to do about
it, right? There's nothing to be done about it. Oh, drama queens
is not bad. I like that. I got the message from kick, guys. I
got it. I got it. Okay. All right. What are we doing next?
What are we doing next? I don't know. I just couple options here.
There's the Bosch thing which I'm not certain about. And hold
on a second. Let me see here. What does the message say? Yeah,
don't worry about it, guys. Don't worry about it.
Let's go to pirate software. I'm gonna I'm gonna stay in the
pirate train.
>> This is a pirate software and and his mod and them doing
the fake hype train. >> first hype train clip. Okay, so
this is a clip where pirate software alt tabs and he's like,
"Let me know if you do bits is going to be the best way to do
it. Due to the return, I'll need you to save it." Bit. So, Pirates
Offer is in the middle of his of his Subathon goal, okay? And
he's telling Kronos, his bod, how to donate in the most efficient
ways to add more time. They let it tick down and they keep adding
more time to it >> rather than T3's. Wait, is this edited
>> Now, I don't know if I would care that much about this
if this was just him like basically trying to keep his thing
going. I don't know if I would care that much, right? Like let's
say hypothetically he was just trying to keep his thing going
in like a situation where he was thinking it could earn him a
little more money or something, right? Like oh this would end
the subathon super quick. Maybe I want it to keep going. That
wouldn't be a big deal. But he's like trying to break a world
record which makes it like a little different. And he's trying
to get people to publish stuff about that world record. It makes
it a totally different thing, right? You might be better but
don't know bits is 82% return when you buy them in bulk if you
bought any yet. I've done 100 T1s in my personal. Ready to do
40 T3s in an alt. Can do bits instead or both. Do 5k bits at
20 seconds left. Okay. What is the alter account? Serendipitous
bean. Where's the beef? Didn't didn't mention this in the mods
either. Now challenge is clear to the bro. What the [__]
is that [__] Bro, wait. They rigging the subathon.
If it's he's just talking to his mod, his mod's like talking
about how he's going to save the subathon. I guess I mean that's
whatever. But if he's if he's reimbursing the mod for gifting
subs to his own subathon to keep it going. Um
that's that's I mean I have a hard time getting that mad about
it if it's just like oh you know I'm a little bit into my subathon
and I want to keep it going and like it would be up if it if
it ended right now, right? I want to lower the price but I don't
want to do it like yet. It's like, okay, that all makes sense
to me, but that's not what he's doing, right? They're just trying
>> That's legit breaking, I'm pretty sure. >> Is
that I don't believe that's real. >> Why would that break
to? Wait, why would that Can somebody explain to me why that
would break to? >> Oh no. >> Why? Why in the would
that break to at >> There's no way that's real, bro. >> Been
a public thing forever. I think I even talked about it on there.
That's against to No, it is not against to. It is absolutely
not against to have somebody use their own money to buy subs
and bits for the channel if they want to. that in no way was
triggered by me nor was he compensated for that or reimbursed
for it. That is
you could say in no way triggered by you. I don't know man. Uh
it sounds like he's trying to loophole if if you doing like if
you like donated to yourself is actually against the rules, right?
I think then maybe maybe if that's against the rules for like
a subathon if that's somehow in the to unaware of it then okay.
It is against the toss to funnel money to people to gift you
subs under the guise of real support. No, but I don't even think
he's funneling money. Doesn't Pirate Software pay his mods? That
mod is getting a big bonus that month. Technically, it could
be. Yes. >> Because of the use of an alt, >> not
against. So, it's a joke at this >> If it's just that it's
on an alt, I literally I still don't care. But >> just
because you heard it on YouTube doesn't mean it is. Yeah. In
fact, I guarantee that you could go to thousands and thousands
of communities across this entire platform and find lots of different
moderators supporting the stream. Do you know why? Because moderators
are generally the first fans of the stream. That is how that
works in every community on this platform. >> Bro, I I've
never ever had a conversation with my mods at all. Like that's
something along the lines of, "Oh yeah, the type train's going
to die. You got me?" >> Uh, in no way triggered by me.
Seems like yes. like he's trying to get around some to thing
like maybe it is bad for you to coordinate donations to yourself
for something or sort of maybe it's beyond just looking bad when
he says in no way triggered by me I think he says does he not
say in the DM explicitly like wait until it's at 0 seconds hold
on let's go back in this did 50k bits at 20 seconds left okay
maybe he's got an argument it sounds like it sounds like the
agreement or the triggering is like before right like it sounds
like they had this conversation before this right so he says
is in no way triggered by me, but it's like they clearly have
an understanding. Did 50k bits at 20 seconds left, right? I easily
see Twitch having problem, but I don't know if it's against the
TOS and the problem would be more he got stuff for his hype train.
>> Based on the context of this, >> never ever had
a conversation with my mods at all. Like >> vlogs before
this leaked. No, I'm saying clearly before that they'd had some
conversation about this. >> That's something along the
lines of, oh yeah, the type train's going to die. You got me.
You got it. That yo, you Yeah. What's the most efficient way?
Like, wait, what's is it better if I do T3 subs or is it better
if I do bits? I never. You literally always say the opposites.
You hate it when you want to get subs. Hey, that dude, it's unhinged.
It's unhinged. Even if we say, okay, he wasn't reimbursing him,
which he probably was based on the context of the situation.
Even if we, bro, it's scum tier behavior to just sit there and
yap to your mod about like trying to coach them on the most efficient
way to give you money at the premium time to make more money
from more people, right? It's it's it's
that's like unfortunately that's like capitalism. People are
going to do that. That that just doesn't shock me. Quinn says
he hasn't done it. I feel like I would expect more streamers
than not to have done that on Twitch. I would just expect that,
right?
>> I don't know. That's just that's my opinion is I I feel
like I would expect a lot of them to do that. I have a hard time
getting outraged at it other than the fact that he like that
he marketed off of breaking like a record or something, right?
I don't think doing it for a record is crazy. But do we really
think we really think when Kaiat did his whole like record subathon
that went forever and he made a of money? Do we really think
that like there was nothing weird going on there? It wasn't like
his agency doing something. There was like nothing really. Really?
Come on. >> Gum tier behavior, bro. Like, if you're you're
talking about metagaming, how to socially engineer people to
give you more money with that guy giving you money in the first
place. Unhinged.
>> Well, somehow don't understand that because you're blinded
by your dislike of me. And I understand that you're upset at
me, but you have to stop making [__] up to be mad
about. It's stupid at this point. Wait, the legal it's I believe
the legal eagle has something to say on that, mate. Yeah, I think
he's full of [__] as well. >> Pirate software
has opened the >> Oh no.
>> Yo, W big W.
>> Not lolly mindset again. This guy's everywhere. I do
kind of respect the hustle. This guy's like decided that I'm
just going to go and tell the whatever like hate mob, whatever
angry people there are on the internet, I'm going to go tell
them that the law is on their side and then they're going to
watch my videos and they're going to pay me a bunch of money
and I'm going to make a bunch of money and by the time anybody
knows what's actually going to happen, I'm off. I'm on the next
controversy, boys. I'm out. He's a bandit. the door to fraud
allegations after a leaked DM shows some controversial
behavior regarding his mod bit donations hype trains and we're
going to get into that today on the legal mind >> half
of the things he says are right
that's that's a fantastic way to say that he'll you back at least
half of the things he says are correct >> set of course
I'm esquire American attorney and this a legal mindset we teach
you to be your own judge in a fast facts format bringing you
the quick and dirty version uh of the latest news. So, Pirate
Software has been in the internet news over the past, I don't
know, three, four, five, six months for various things that he
has been doing. Uh, but now we have him actually getting caught
in something where there could be real legal liability. Now,
to be very clear, we are not addressing the drama today. So,
we're not going to talk about how he got his party. No, we're
not going to we're not going to remind everybody of why they
hate Pirates Offer real quick, guys. You want to go down memory
lane? Remember why you hate this guy? >> Wow. And how he
failed to even give a basic apology and say, "Hey, look, listen.
This was really my fault. I could have done more here." Not try
to deflect it, not try to blame everybody equally, but just take
responsibility and know about that. We're not talking about any
of the uh fig tree allegations
and whatever he did with a ferret. That's between him and the
ferret. Uh, we're also not talking about stop games, although
we did talk about that on a previous episode. >> Quinn's
reaction. I am watching Quinn's reaction. I'm literally watching,
we're on Quinn's reaction commentary. Uh, however, one thing
we are going to talk about is this fall in subs because a lot
of this does have to do with the fact that Pirate Software due
to all these controversies is >> actual Packwatch. Fast
facts. This guy sucks. Let's let's packwatch this guy. So, [__]
this guy. >> Dance on this dude's grave. Fast facts. when
you are hemorrhaging subs, and I'll bring this up again at the
end, this opens you up to a lot of potential problems from people
that used to be supporters. So, obviously, in the over 104,000
people as of date, over the last just 30 days, losing over 104K
followers, amongst those certainly are some whales, some people
that donated a lot to his channel and now feel really, really
hurt, feel betrayed by Pirate Software. And whenever you have
that happen, not only are you going to have more people paying
attention to your channel, more people looking for you to make
mistakes, more people logging what you're doing, >> I'm
not following legal mindset at all. What is he even on about
right now? Like what is he even on about right now? Like legit,
what is he on about? >> Increasing potential like
>> ability because one of those people any of those people
>> when you lose subs that means your former viewers I
guess hate you is like what he's former viewers will go back
and like I I think that's his general argument, right? your your
former viewers are going to go back and remember the bad things
you did and bring them up now. >> People that donated a
lot that felt they gave a lot might have claimed or cause if
you end up slipping up and they felt misled and that might generate
some sort of cost of action and that's something we might have
here today. So let's get into it. What happened? So Pirate Software
while live accidentally showed a DM with his moderator. That
DM shows that his mod was purchasing bits to extend Pirates hype
train. Now, that's a Twitch thing. And we're over here on YouTube.
We We only have hype trains and you guys smashing the like button
and commenting on the video. Uh, which is all appreciated.
>> Uh, but that's
like Quinn's not the biggest fan that record repeatedly. In fact,
only recently, I believe the VTuber Vital Neurosama over there,
uh, beat his record. But previously, he'd been setting records
as related to this hype train. So it's something >> the
top hight train guys like a compulsive narcissistic liar and
the other one's a
>> this is the world we live in. All right >> that
you know as a channel if you're >> Wow. Awesome. >> Records
you're typically pretty proud of that. Now it appears his DM
in the DM with his moderator it appears his DM was purchasing
bits to extend Pirates hype train. Now by and in and of itself
and we're going to see that with the terms of service etc. that
probably wouldn't be a problem if the if the moderator was doing
that on their moderator account, right? And the moderator was
just as a moderator
going and donating those bits. However,
uh it was beyond just the moderator doing it. The moderator was
donating them not with their main account, but with an alt account,
which the mod made pirate aware of and which presented itself
not as the mod, but as a friend of the mod. As a >> it's
an intent to deceive, right? And collusion 100%. It's
>> Wait, hold on. Intent to deceive. Okay, >> it's
like a >> Why for like a donation? Why does the public
have the right to know that it's like me as a different person?
I don't even know. I don't know why. Huh?
>> It would depend on how widespread it was. I just I'm
not sure that like it's one of those things where it's like,
okay, these two people want to donate money in this way. Why
does it why does it matter for like the what the public sees?
If the platform doesn't like it, then maybe, right? Like colloquially,
I don't think Quinn's wrong, but legally, is there like legal
exposure there would be what I'd want to know. >> It's
more It's not like a one-step process. It's a multi-step process
in order to deceive >> separate person who was not the
mod, which is not true. We're going to see that right today.
So, I'm going to pull up the actual footage. >> Why do
you think they use alts? Because I'm guessing that basically
they don't want it being like tracked exactly how much like uh
what's his name? exactly how much Kronos is like keeping it alive
by himself, right? But it seemed like Kronos already donated
a lot and his mods were already donating a lot >> uh for
this. Of course, if you want to catch the full analysis, right,
the full breakdown, uh you can always always catch the uh the
full version on my live. So, here is Pirate Software, and this
is the moment in which he was caught in 4K uh showing the DM.
So, here's him. >> The guy with the bucking. He's got the
goddamn He's got He's got like uh some sort of What's that program
that we used to use at school? Uh where he's got slides. He's
It's the boomer technique. He's He's got a PowerPoint, bro. And
he's talking about his live, man. This guy's old school, man.
Okay, don't get it twisted. >> Bring gameplay. >> I
could place my head between them and go full bur mode and make
>> what? Okay, so here's where he pulls it up. Here's the
the screenshot. We're going to go into it. I'm going to read
it through, but here's the screenshot and you can see how fast
he's going to click away from this. He's just going to try to
clear this out because obviously >> Hold on. Do we get
all of this
>> as what the alt account is? >> So, this is him
pulling it up on stream here. And I'll just go ahead and let
them see that this is indeed pirate software. You can see his
messages between Kronos, the ones that we were just showing you.
And then you're going to watch. >> So, you can see he's
got it up here. He's going to click. >> This has happened
to me probably like 27 times, by the way. I've like Discord's
opened up. Boom. DMs to insert anyone. Insert anyone and everyone.
I've I've leaked DMs with my Twitch partners.
I've leaked like my managers. I've linked DMs with [__]
Sod Poppin. I've leaked DMs with Mat. I've leaked DMs with Z.
I've leaked every like dude to my mod conversations.
Holy I just dude Discord is real bad for this. How come it like
like, "Hey, do you want to instantly open up your DMs?" >> This
is just insane cope. Yeah, Discord will open up to the page you
left it on. It's how every application in the world works. Why
would Why would this be different? How annoying would it be for
every non-streamer in the world if it didn't just pull up whatever
you last had up? There's literally a streamer >> capture
so it doesn't see this. >> That's what I do. But I I Dude,
he's like actually not thinking about how most people would use
his app. He's just like, "Why doesn't this work the best way
for you could put it in stream mode and say like every time I
maximize this application, I want like if if this application's
been inactive for like 15 seconds, I want it to go to like some
saver screen, some screen saver or something like some neutral
thing where I have to click." That's weird. >> Do you want
to instantly open up like the, you know, like the secret you're
talking about? Like, let me just link >> Click away, right?
He clicks away pretty quickly, right, to get over here. Um, and
by the way, another thing, big credit credit to Quinn Theo. I'm
going to tag his video in the video below for bringing this up
and for making this uh presentation and kind of collecting this
together. But in that screenshot, we have some pretty damning
proof uh that he was talking with
moderator in order to uh engage in >> Yeah, but it's really
easy to fat finger or accidentally be focused on Discord instead
of your browser and hotkey into your DMs on accident. Maybe.
I mean, I've probably leaked like some stuff before. I don't
think I've ever really had a big DM leak, but I use application
capture, so it's pretty difficult for me to actually leak stuff
>> in this behavior. So, let's look at this here. I'm going
to read through this for you guys so you get it. So, pirate software
says, "Let me know if you do bits is going to be the best way
to do it due to the return if you need to save it." So, what
he's talking about is what is the most efficient way for you
to buy these bits and then extend the hype train? And the return
would imply that he's going to get money back, that he's going
to get reimbursed. So that implies that as this moderator is
donating, Pirate Software is going to pay him back for what he
gets. So it's going to be returned to him. So he's going to get,
as Pirate Software says, like an 82 Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. What the I'm sorry to like totally break out of this. Okay,
but what is this? Aelia Banks tweet. Someone just linked this
to me. It's through Anthony Fantana, which is unfortunate, but
what the Okay, in Donald Trump's defense, 14-year-old girls was
really only made a social taboo in the 1990s. My grandmother
was born in 1927 and had her first child when she was 12. Teenage
pregnancy only became frowned upon with the rise of Jerry Springer.
And I also can be honest about the fact that I was old enough
to choose, seduce, and decide to [__] a grown grown
ass man when I was 15. I really don't get why women are fronting
like they weren't 40-year-olds at 14. Like, come on now. I'm
honestly not surprised or mad at Trump for getting some 15-year-old
because those were the >> Listen, in the '9s, isn't that
what she said? It wasn't. >> That's what she just said.
That's what she just said.
>> Time it became not normal. He was doing it at that time.
I don't know. >> Her own defense doesn't work. >> I
I actually think Yeah. No, I don't know, dude. I have no idea.
Lolita came out in '98. Okay, bro. I don't know. I don't know.
Wow.
Just when you thought she couldn't get worse, dude. Is Hold on.
A uh Aelia
lace wig. She not have this up. I want to see if people are responding
to this tweet. What the Dude, she's tweeting a lot to probably.
Yeah, hold on. Here it is. This one. Okay. Oh, she added more.
Hold on. She added more. Good night, USA for ever. Now, if he
was a 10-year-old, we have a problem. But if the girls were 13
plus, who cares? Move on. It got worse. It got worse. It got
worse. It actually got worse. I didn't think it could get worse,
but it got worse. Dude, what the >> Wait. And the problem
is like they were traffic as well. Wait, what are we >> I
don't know what the is going on, dude. This is crazy. What the?
Yeah, true, dude. What in the Oh [__] >> Is
that >> Hold on. responds because little Spanish girls
be at 13 in middle school with DD plus and giving very much.
Humans are going to do what humans are going to do. Britney,
Simon and Joyer,
humans going to human. I am not trying to anything under the
age of 45, but it is what it is. Goodness gracious. Forget about
the Epstein files. Who cares?
>> Oh my god. >> Bruh. Bruh. Dude, what? What is
happening? Why? What? Huh? Huh? What? What? What? What? These
are some wild tweets. I don't know where the this is coming from.
She's running for president 2028. I don't know, man. >> You
remember that? Like I don't even There's like this one week like
after FD files like some was it Trump? I don't know. Some like
yo, these Democrats are in lock step. I just couldn't believe
that came out of the Republicans's mouth. Jesus Christ, >> dude.
I am so Dude, nobody I feel like this is the most ba Oh, extreme
dad coming in with the extreme dad take. This is the most based
opinion I've ever heard. I agree too. Yes, of course. Of course.
This is what we'd expect Extreme Dad to say. Yes. Yes. Extreme
Dad and Aelia Banks have a lot of like overlap. Okay. It get
Wait, it gets worse. Wait, what? Huh? Hold on. What is this?
What is this post? Hold on. Mama, a whole lot of went down back
in the day that was awful and the and was not okay, including
all of this includ tweet. But you're here, right? I'm sure everyone
alive was born to a teenage mother or has older siblings that
your mom had when she was young, a young hoe. And humanity needs
to give itself more time to wean off of a young before we are
branding people 16-year-olds. Like, we need another hundred years
of not girls under 21 to be the norm before we are throwing darts.
And how are we going to throw darts and champions change surgery
for 10-year-olds and realistically not view that as overt? At
least a is still within the boundaries of normal. Mutilating
children is not. Wow. Wow. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay.
Okay. Okay. All right. Okay. Trans people destroyed everyone's
brains. They really did, didn't they? Not a lot of views on it
because it got shadowbanned. Oh, probably 34. She only got 34
likes, bro.
Oh, 40,000 views, 34 likes. >> Ain't nobody want to throw
a like on this tweet.
>> That's like insanely insanely
>> I didn't even know who you were until your comment on
Expo Trump. You are a piece of and your whole family should be
embarrassed. No teenagers should be Donald Trump teenagers with
Epstein. This is probably the that lawsuit. Jesus. Extreme dad
just saying um extreme dad things trying to get on stream or
something. No, we don't care. Don't just say to try to get on
stream. We know you don't believe this. We know you don't believe
this. We know you don't believe this. We know you don't believe
this. Even on the fence, even off the fence, you don't believe
this. Stop. Stop making things up. Extreme dad. Bro, what the
is Banks? >> No, no, no, no. I think he's just talking
about the ratio of how much gets converted to pirates pocket.
>> T3 might be better. Don't know. Okay, this is 82% return
when you buy them in bulk. Have you my >> stuff? Hold on,
hold on, hold on. Okay, so this is the donation >> description
here, >> right? Which is already win accounts. >> So,
I'm skipping forward before he keeps >> remember that name
serendipitous be going to come up. Where's the beef? And then
he goes on to say, didn't mention this to the mods either. Now,
the challenge is to clear the queue. The Q is referring to his
kind of backup TTSQ, which he has to clear or it's donated to
charity. But the more important thing is this serendipitous bean.
And here's this profile here. And this information courtesy of
Guy on Twitter. So thank you guy. Uh this was the description
here of Serendipitous Bean. IRL friend of Kronos. So Kronos is
the main moderator and excited that they are free from corporate.
Love your stream and what you do for the people here. There aren't
many cooler supported streamers left once they get big like this.
Stay cool bud and tell Kronos that Ben sends their >> Hey
everybody. >> It's like kind of goofy. It is goofy that
you're like taking your time to make up a backstory for yourself.
Okay. Why not just literally just donate and don't say anything?
Why would that be a problem? Just donate. Just give the money
and don't say >> so this person is >> yo dude B sends
their regards dude he's talking to coded bro
get that he's like
transfer complete. >> Oh god they know.
>> nothing of this transaction dude we're fooling everyone.
Oh my Yo and it's Ben dude. Is that Ben_? No. This is that coded
message man. Oh my god. >> It's not It's not coded at all.
Where's the coding? The code was the DM saying, "I'm gonna donate
under this name." This is not a coded message. >> This
is crazy. >> Clearly painting them >> No, he's not
memeing
as not Kronos, not the moderator, but a separate IRL friend of
this moderate, which is extremely deceptive if you ask me. Now,
how does this convert to a >> is I don't think he's joking.
Well, there's three potential legal questions and these were
brought up also by Quint Theo in his very good video which once
again I'm going to link in the comment below. He brought up the
first two third one here. So the first one is Twitch terms of
service. Then we have federal law violations and state law violations.
So let's look at the Twitch terms of service. So obviously Twitch
has a terms of service. There's many things. >> Quint is
a different guy. It's not. Trust me. Trust me. Quint Theo sends
his
>> Things you can and cannot do. But one thing they have
is called a bit acceptable use policy. So you're supposed to
use bits in a certain way. You're supposed to behave like a normal
contributor and not do certain impermissible things. Like for
example, you can't solicit bits in exchange for money or donations.
Uh that's one thing. You can't provide items or services that
are associated with monetary value in exchange for bits. And
a big thing here, and this is one that I think he has to really
watch out for, is selling, offering to sell, trading, bartering,
or transferring bits to other users in exchange for real or virtual
currencies. So, if this mod is using these bits and transferring
them to pirate software, and pirate software is converting that
to cash and paying him back, that would appear to violate the
toos.
>> Okay. But hold on. Is there proof that he's doing that
beyond just paying his mods? There would have to be proof that
he's like paying them back or reimbursing them for this, right?
Beyond just what he actually pays them because he already has
them salaried from before this. So, it would have to it would
depend on what he's like like is that salary. So, we'll see.
We'll see. We'll >> But realistically, this could I didn't
see anything where he's like, "Okay, I'll pay you back here."
Right. >> Um, you cannot use the bits to engage any fraudulent
criminal or otherwise unauthorized activity, soliciting or receiving
bids for any fraudulent or any other criminal activity. That
could be a problem because of the nature of what they did because
they engaged. >> Wait, wait. Selling >> because so
it's fraudulent because they donate under I don't know that there's
any policy that says you can't donate under like a a pseudonym.
I don't think that exists. >> Offering to sell, trading,
battery, and transferring beds in to other users of Twitch in
exchange for this
>> or virtual currency. So real currency. So that Okay.
So if he's basically if he's paying his mod, he's >> Yeah.
Ciphy, I will uh I'll go and take a look at the the bonuses and
exactly what's going on. >> Break into your >> I
have I have those pictures. I have those. We we'll keep going
here. >> He's break if he's paying his money break. So
if you get if a mod does that and then Gam broke whenever he
donated whatever thousand account went into >> Yeah. That
a mod can very well be perceived as an agent or an employee of
the streamer. So if a mod goes out and does something on the
streamer's behalf, they're an agent and a streamer is what called
the principal. That's principal agent theory. And >> my
agent my agent can be liable for the actions of their agent.
If you tell somebody to go out and do something and certainly
if you're compensating them or reimbursing them for that, they
are your agent. So it's as if the streamer was doing this. So
it's as if pirate >> So I don't even know from pirate software's
thing. Did he even know did he even like force that guy or ask
that guy Kronos to go on a different account or is that just
something that >> engaging in this? And in this case it's
doubly damning because he shows he knows this. He was told this
and he didn't say don't do that. He didn't say well that might
be against to he says well that's kind of shady. No he's like
okay great. He's like okay fine. >> Lord but the thing
is it could be one or the other. He could just be manipulating
the guy in a super weird parasocial way and milking him like
a paper which is up and you know ethically dubious is I mean
I think it's scum t behavior right so it's either scum behavior
or >> pirate said he did it on his own well I >> doing
illegal and also scum behavior right you got two options you
got it's both bad at a and bad b like really bad >> fact
he's strategizing on the best way to do this which is once again
not a very good look when we're coming to allegations of fraud
so let's continue here we have federal No, sorry. Let me go back
here. Um, with the terms of service, some people allege, and
this is more of a a kind of niche uh allegation,
some people do allege, and this is something that I believe one
of the lawyers brought up uh for this was that well uh this is
something that there might be a separate contract for. Uh so
the lawyer that was talking to Quinn Theo said, "Hey, there might
be a separate contract that might supersede that." Well, in a
separate part of the Twitch terms of service, which I looked
up, it actually says even in
>> what is that
>> space goes? thing to get the sub to pink >> other
agreements even if there's a separate agreement even if there's
a supplement you still have to follow these terms and you cannot
violate them and I'm very sure that a separate agreement would
have incorporated that statement because it's intended to be
applied to all separate agreements. So, even if there was a separate
private streamer agreement, even if Pirate Software got >> No,
Kronos is in chat. We have the real >> spelled differently.
You suck at every game. A what the [__] >> Break
those terms. And beyond that, he's not allowed to break the law.
And what we get into next, and the thing that's very spicy is
potential violations of federal law and state law. So, let's
talk about federal law. Federal law is the Federal Deceptive
Trade Practices Act. And that's something that uh is very, very
well known by me. I covered that a lot. That was one of my kind,
I would say, specialties uh in the corporate realm uh when I
was at corporate council. uh there are three separate elements.
So you need a representation, omission or practice that is likely
to mislead a customer. So the practice would be hey donating
bits from the sock puppet account. The consumer's interpretation
is reasonable under the circumstances. So the consumer is thinking
this is a private party. This is somebody else. This is not the
mod. This is not pirate software. They're thinking, oh look,
this person >> okay. Why I'm just curious. Would you have
to have a reasonable expectation that like that would change
a consumer's mind if they knew it was a mod? Cuz I think the
mods already donated a lot to this, right? Like, is there any
reason to believe that people would not donate to this thing
if it was just a mod donating in the first place? If it was a
mod pay instead of some other random pay, right? Like, if it's
a mod, would that really have changed anybody's mind? If Kronos
didn't do that and he just did it under his own account, is he
receiving less money? Is Pirate Software receiving less money?
I understand that there's like probably some additional element
of, oh, there's lots of different people participating that probably
gives people FOMO. They want to get in, they want to spend their
money. I understand that a little bit, but like it's it's not
like that far off to me. >> And so because of that, because
of that misleading representation that materially led others
to donate more to keep it going, it's a very well-known thing
in scams and cons. This is something that confidence men do.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. The the the Paris scams. So they'll
have a guy at Paris, like we were just watching um where there'll
be a guy like winning, right? There'll be a guy winning. Okay.
There'll be the ball scam and he But he's in on it, right? He's
in on it. and you're like, "Look, it's so easy." >> Yeah,
but that's deceiving somebody into something that they can't
win, right? Nobody the product is not lessened because these
other people donated, right? The whole thing with the scam that
this Quinn is about to lay out is that that person you can't
win when you go to play the ball game. So, somebody wins and
you get the the confidence that you can go in and win, but you
are getting objectively
in this in this situation. You don't get less time on the stream
because this guy donated bits. You get you get everything you
paid for. to win. You just press the You just point at the right
one and then that's the one and then you just get money. I can
do that. Oh yeah. Just like, oh, look, this guy's donating and
doing it. Do you know what? I could do that. We could keep this
high train going. Let's go, boys. It's the same. It's it's it's
not even remotely the same. This is the dumbest thing I've ever
heard. I should probably be less hyperbolic. I've heard the dumbest
thing I've ever heard like four times today. This is very dumb.
Okay, this is very, very dumb. >> Like gustoing you up,
right? It's getting you up to then basically it's to play you
and to scam you and to take your money, punk, which is 100% what
it is, right? If you'll get if you've got a mod um it's not like
viewbotting either, charging Jim, it's not like viewbotting either.
Viewbotting defrauds Twitch.
This does not defraud Twitch. It's not like viewbotting. Nobody
is being harmed here except arguably the people who are like,
"Oh, one extra person decided to donate a bunch of money. We
all love Pirate Software. I I I can see Pirate Software is loved."
Like there's a little element of that, but nobody is actually
losing out on something they would pay for and get back here.
Nobody's being scammed
that is intentionally artificially not. >> By the way,
I hate pirate software. I I love dog piling on this guy. I love
I love with this guy, right? >> Organically, they weren't
deceptive.
It is deceptive, but nobody is losing something out of this,
right? Everybody gets exactly They're not misrepresenting what
you get out of what you're paying for, right? This is like saying
that McDonald's making their burger look different is like the
worst practice in the world, right? You know how they they make
the burger the burger on the picture doesn't really look like
the burger that you get? It's like that difference. It's it's
even less bad than that difference. >> Extending a hype
train to try uh you know milk as much money from your audience
as possible via deceptive means, right? >> Fake buyers
to go out there and jin up interest so that people will buy stuff
even though it's overpriced. That is a very common fraudulent
practice. but buy stuff so it's where it's overpriced. But that
this would involve like uh artificially manipulating the market
in some way, right? >> So by not disclosing the fact that
essentially your agent, your employee is going out here and doing
that, that is misleading a reasonable viewer, a reasonable consumer.
That's a possible interpretation of that. Once again, it's not
for sure that he would be convicted of this, but this is opening
up the door to these. >> So requires surveillance. The
presentation, the representation, omission, or practice is likely
to mislead a consumer. So this is federal law for fraud, I'm
guessing. Federal Deceptive Trade Practices Act. The consumer's
interpretation is reasonable under the circumstances and the
misleading representation, omission, or practice is material.
Hold on, dude. I shouldn't even have I shouldn't even have Quinn's
in here. It's like a total waste. I should just go grab the stuff
that he's looking at. Where's my fast facts on this? Pirates
software. Pirates software. Pirates software. Oh, it's got to
be up here. Fastf facts. Pirate software. Right here. >> As
the mod, but >> federal federal federal federal federal
federal federal federal right here. We continue. Federal law
violations. Thank you. The misleading representation omission
or practice is material. Uh, hold on. I I literally would have
to look this up. >> I feel like if we went and looked this
up, if we went and looked up this law, we would find that like
there has to be some harm to the person, right? That they're
being they're being like built out of value somehow that like
if if it's if there if if you paid somebody like there's no way
you could sue me for fraud. If I paid somebody to walk by my
storefront and go, "Oh my god, that's a really cool thing." And
then somebody goes in and buys the thing that they just said
was really cool. Like, oh, that's a really cool thing. I give
the money. That's a really cool thing. They go in and buy this
thing that I have a thousand of, right? And somebody else walks
along and they go, "Oh, that guy just bought it. I should actually
Oh my god, that's a really cool thing. I saw it as bad." Like
there's no tangible harm to the party, right? There's no They're
getting the same product they would pay for anyway. >> Look,
this person >> It's totally misleading. I just don't know
if it's like fraud. What is the legal
definition? Fraud in legal terms, fraud is the broad concept
encompassing intentional deception or misrepresentation used
to gain something of value or to cause harm to another.
I'm trying to think of like how this happens. So used to gain
something of value. So it is used to gain money. It's like borderline
deceptive advertising, right? Again, I'm just trying to think
if Kronos had if Kronos had donated from his own account. I think
nobody does nobody have a problem with this. Is the problem that
Pirate Software is talking to Kronos about his donations or is
the problem that Kronos is making the donation under an alt?
What is the bigger issue? Cuz I I think probably to most people
they're like, "Oh, it's that it's on an alt." And to me, it's
like probably the fact that Pirate Soft is colluding with him
to keep it going. I don't know if it's good to use AI like this.
It's fine to use AI like this. It's literally giving me a definition.
That's so stupid. Oh god. in law in fraud is intentional deception
to deprive a victim of a legal right or to gain from the victim
unlawfully or unfairly. That's the thing. Unfairly. Are you unfairly
gaining? I don't think so. I don't think so. There's no unlawful
or un unfair thing here. Okay. This you guys are I'm literally
just looking for what like you would consider this. I'm literally
looking for like a layman's definition of what this would be.
I said legal. I just This is This is better. This is better.
This It's very clear that we would not do it through this, right?
Wait, King Gidra, do you think I had an issue with Natserite
using AI >> or you think I had an issue with her like not
disclosing that? I don't have an issue with people using AI.
>> I have no issue with people using AI. It's like when
you're having a conversation if I was having a conversation with
someone, right, and I was using AI to like argue with them without
telling them. That would be weird. Alts are deceptive. Alts are
deceptive. But is it are you doing it to deprive the victim of
a legal right or to gain from the victim unlawfully or unfairly?
Lying is not illegal. Lying to defraud somebody. Lying to take
from someone uh unfairly or unlawfully is illegal. Lying itself
is not illegal. I don't think I don't even know that it actually
I don't even know if it actually blocks or if it violates the
concept of a subathon. Like I don't know if there's any toos
around a subathon. Would you consider false reviews fraud? H
I don't know. Like I would consider it lying. I would consider
a deceptive practice. This is all like this is a like realistically
not all just fall under false advertising. I'm trying to think
of like where this because to me I'm like okay this is like goofy
but realistically I don't know if it's like the worst practice
in the world. Twitch nobody is being like uh built out of their
money to me. FCC rules around paid endorsement but without disclosure
are very much illegal. Your shop example not Thor. Okay. Yeah
sure. Paying for advertising paying for testimonials. Would this
come under like paying for testimonials? No. Cuz you Sorry. I
actually would have to pay that person. I included something
that didn't exist. If I got my if my friend did that for me out
of their own free will would be the example, right? My friend
shows up outside of my shop and goes, "Dude, this is awesome."
He walks in and he buys something and other people walk in and
buys something cuz he's like, "Right. Is that illegal? That's
actually better." Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Zan Cali. Yes. Yes. Yes.
Yes. I'm I'm including something there. That's my bad. I don't
know that he pays these people. I don't know that they get paid
in proximity to their donations or approximately for their donations.
Right. I think we're going to look at something in a little bit
that shows that he possibly gives extra money to them. Is this
morally wrong? It's like right on the line. Like all all deception
and lying is morally wrong, but I don't know what their goal
is in in like doing this, right? Is it like that? Is it that
Kronos gets made fun of for being a pay and he doesn't like that?
So, he's going on an alt to not get made fun of for being a pay.
Is that morally wrong for him to pay pee from an alt because
he doesn't like getting made fun of for pay pegging from his
main? Is that Is that now morally wrong? What if he didn't include
Pirate in this at all? What if he didn't tell Pirate he was donating
from an alt? Is that morally wrong? Is it morally wrong because
Pirate didn't say, "No, no, no, no, no. Don't do that. You You're
my mod. You can't donate from an alt." There is some amount of
collusion here. Sure. If that was the reason, then why put a
fake message? Because it it confirms he's lying. He knows that.
And he says he's friends of Kronos. Wait, what? What do you mean
why put a fake message? How does the fake message not help that
same thing? What? You tell him the fi financially best way to
do it to make sure he loses the least amount of money when you
pay him back. Hold on. Hold on. You just included some stuff
there that I don't know is included in those DMs. Right, Potteros?
It's not about like, hey, this is how I'll pay you back the most
efficiently. It's like how can you best contribute to the subathon?
I thought this was like return in terms of the subathon, the
best thing to buy in terms of the subathon. >> Uh, beyond
that, there's state law. So, Twitch is in California. Every state
has their own deceptive practices act. Florida has one, Georgia
has one, New York. A lot of them follow what's called the UDTPA,
which is the Uniform Deceptive Trade Practices Act. But some
of them also have things that go further and some of them have
criminal penalties, uh, including California, uh, which can hit
you if you go cross certain lines. So, Consumer Legal Remedies
Act, California has that, and I mentioned California, by the
way, because that's where Twitch is. So, it would be very reasonable
if a California donor, if a California, >> it's clearly
wrong to rig a contest where the rewards are monetary. But hold
on, it's Oh, there's got to be a good example of this, right?
Like maybe it enters the realm of fraudulent when you do it under
the pretense of we're going to break a record and then you're
not breaking the record organically, right? Maybe it's when you're
trying to break this record and it's not being done organically.
That could be that could be fair, right? But honestly, like just
in a general hype train, I don't think that's necessarily all
that bad. Crowd warmers for entertainment acts surely had said
a lot of history around it. Okay, I'm I'm going to So crowdwarmers,
those would be people that you would be paying, right? Or would
that be people you let do it for free? It crosses some Where
is money cycling happening? Xan Cali. Where is money cycling
happening? It crosses the line for me with money cycling.
Where who is cycling money? S Kyoko, you got to you got to explain
to me where money is cycling cuz I I see something later and
we can just pull this up because we're doing this legal mindset
[__] but this is uh this is from earlier this year,
2025. The early Giga Train will be on April 1st, 2025. Our previous
record in 2024 was level 106 at 47%. Veto beat it in Janu on
January 1st with level 111 at 55% train. If you would like to
take part in this, I will see you there. I also have a surprise
that I've been keeping from this the team until now. Over the
last couple of months, we've had to deal with an insane amount
of moderation work. What the team does allows this place to be
as cool as it is, and I want to recognize that this year. 50%
of the giga train will be given as a bonus to all the staff members
outside of myself. For those who don't know, the moderators and
other staff are full-time salaried employees. They also receive
medical, vision, dental, and life insurance. This bonus is in
addition to their base pay. Thank you all for an amazing year,
and I hope to see you on this glorious April Fool's Day. Okay,
so now this is where are we is this cycling is this cycling money?
Like, are the are the moderators more incentivized to participate
in this? So there so are they incentivized to participate in
this? It's low tier moneyaundering.
It's money laundering where where you lose money. It's it's like
laundering money to Twitch. Zanic Kelly, it's just efficiency.
It's just efficiency in terms of like I don't want to like if
you just want to add more time to the hype train. Here's the
most efficient way to do it. I tell I tell everybody on stream,
hey, if you want to if you just want to add more time to stream,
it's a 955 split on kick. Sub through kick, right? I don't think
that's like wrong. It's like literally this is the part that
takes the least cut. We need the timeline. Well, the timeline
is obviously going to be that this is this is made clear to everybody,
right? But to me, it's like, okay, 50% of the gigata train bonus
will be given to staff members or giga train will be given to
staff members. So stuff from this based on how far we go, like
they could be incentivized to give money, but I don't think they
could be forced or else Thor would be opening himself up to like
a a like penalties. Would it incentivize them to donate? Yes.
Would that be totally wrong? Maybe. Maybe this is all totally
wrong in some way. Isn't this like pretending you're doing a
going out of business sale and then you don't close? It might
be kind of like that. Sure. It's like one of those things that
like I don't really deny that it's scummy, right? I do think
it's scummy. It's like weird kind of gross sales tactics. People
are manipulated into believing prices are lowest. That's clo
I'd say it's like manipulating sentiment. But the thing is is
you're not saying things are on sale here. You're manipulating
people into wanting to participate, but they're getting the there's
like no price change and the money and the thing they're getting
for their dollars is still the same either way, right? It's going
to be kind of like taking money for a Kickstarter and then not
releasing a game after 9 years. I'd say it's way less scummy
than that actually. I think this is like about as honest as I've
seen Pirate Software operate, which is kind of [__]
up. Yeah, I would say the scummyiness like I'd say at all like
having your moderators typing to you about how they're going
to donate to keep it going, but then oh man, like some of my
mods are people who have donated money to me and if I wanted
to do that with a hype train, I don't know if that's like the
worst thing in the world. I don't know. It's like uh it's sketchy.
Like it's bad. It's just bad to lie to people. Okay, that is
bad. But in totality, I just don't know that this is like something
I would expect most people not to do. Every story that comes
out about Pirate, it's evident that everything about him is fake.
Yeah, it's not bad because mods donated. It's bad because they
tried to hide who is donating. Maybe I'd say like Cher's hit
it as well that it's like it's it's the deceptive practice to
make people think that they can get in. Maybe there's something
as well that like oh we're only going to donate if we have to
like as the timer goes low. Like that could be another thing,
right? >> I think if you want to pay your mods, you morally
have to bar them from donating.
Why? All of this is like money going to Thor and or like you're
psych. So this is one of those things where it's like uh you're
not making money by doing this, right? You're not like you're
not making a money by doing this. You're like paying ridiculous.
This is like all ego. You're coming out like worse for doing
this monetarily. Like everybody is. The the inefficiency of donating
through Twitch is like absolutely painful here, right? Like Twitch
taking a 20% premium on everything. That's rough in my opinion.
You could probably actually figure this out. You've seen the
clip. Yeah, I realized he pays his mod a salary. He's never not
paid his mods a salary. So, he paid his mods a salary before
this hype train happened, right? I think he's paid his mods a
salary for a while now. So, like I think given how much you have
to pay through to Twitch to like make these donations, I just
don't know that you're coming out ahead by like, oh, I'm actually
going to give you 50% of your donations back in the form of like
a bonus. And but that's not just 50% of your donations. That's
50% of all donations to the entire hype train, right? So, he's
giving his mods a lot of money here, especially if they're doing
record-breaking hype trains. Man, it's uh what is there? There
are two of these, right? Okay, let's see. This is afterwards.
He says, "This got all the numbers in for the Giga Train. You
guys have asked a total of $75,000. It was slightly less, so
I rounded it up. Half of the Giga Train comes out to $37,500.
We currently have a staff size of 15, not counting me. This split
evenly for all staff members comes out to $2,500. This bonus
will be applied to everyone in the or outside of myself. The
payments will go out at the end of this month. The other $37,500
will be applied towards the ferret rescue. I'm putting I'm putting
together all of the cash to make sure we have enough for construction.
Still waiting on the contractors and county to come to terms.
Thank you for everything you do. Yeah, he doesn't even take the
money from it. Like realistically, this is mostly ego farming.
This Sorry, now that he's not taking any money, this is all ego
farming for him, right? Like and I fully believe he would have
paid a bunch of his own money back in in some way or I wouldn't
be shocked. Like I don't know. You look at all this. I wouldn't
be shocked if he was paying the mods directly for doing it to
be honest with you about his value. Yes. That's probably the
biggest the biggest offense here is like he's pretending that
he's getting stuff done that he's like a made guy that he's that
it's all fake numbers, right? >> And I'm I'm not even saying
that that's not bad. It is bad to like fake your numbers. It
is bad. Obviously lying is wrong. I don't know if it's I don't
know how crazy Dude, what the why is there 44 star stars of David
on this? >> I don't know. >> What the hell? What
the Ukraine flag? What the
um
Okay. He's a con man. Yeah, he's a he's a con man in some ways.
Yeah, he's like a piece of I don't know if the the coordination
on the hype train is the worst part of what he does. It's probably
just indicative of like a lot of the other things he does being
fake, right? Yeah. I don't know. Anyway, let's go back to legal
mindset telling us how illegal this is. The real meme is that
everyone hates it because Thor got an eager boost and we all
hate this now. I mean, that's really what it comes down to, right?
whale brought a cla Oh, I'm actually not going to keep watching
through Quinn though. Sorry. Sorry. The hype train. And so because
of that, because of that misleading representation that materially
led others to donate more to keep it going. It's a very well-known
>> Well, DG Glazer
says there was Yeah, there were news articles which equals money
for him. I see this. I suspect that he probably was emailing
those places to go, "Hey, did you notice that Pirate Software
broke the record for this?" which yes it folds into some unreasonable
and and immoral practices almost certainly >> thing in
scams and cons this is something that confidence men do they
get fake buyers to go out there and jin up interest so that people
will buy stuff even though it's overpriced that is a very common
fraudulent practice so by not disclosing the fact that essentially
your agent your employee is going out here and doing that that
is misleading a reasonable viewer a reasonable consumer that's
a possible Consumer Legal Remedies Act. California has that.
And I mentioned California, by the way, because that's where
Twitch is. >> I just I don't know if it's quite the same
as some of the actual harmful practices, right? That's charging
people that's getting people to buy things at the wrong price.
That's like I don't believe that. >> So, it would be very
reasonable if a California donor, if a California whale brought
a claim against a California corporation in a California court
against, you know, Twitch and against uh you know, Mr. M >> awen
pirate software. So there's >> and he's proposing that
like a whale donator would go and sue for like man I don't know
>> things that uh really come up and these are separate
under the law the consumer legal remedies. >> I'd say probably
all my condemnation here is not any consumer practice. No no
violation no fraud. It's just like yeah it's the deception and
and building a false reputation as like a bigger streamer than
he actually was right that he's going to use his money to it's
moneyaundering. It is not moneyaundering. That is [__]
>> Money laundering. >> It's not moneyaundering.
That's stupid, right? Uh it it's just the deceptive practice
of building up his own like reputation. Building up his own like
he's building this reputation that he's this massive streamer.
He's got all this going on, right? I assume there's a whole bunch
of other things going along with this that actually would be
worse. And like like who doubts that he like view bots or something
now, right? Moneyaundering doesn't mean you give money to yourself.
I know the whole point of money laundering is taking illegal
money and making it clean. It's not money laundering at all.
It's so stupid, but it's fine. It's fine. >> Now, that's
typically used to products, but there could be an >> does
he view that, but like I feel like this is the same practice
as viewing from his point of view. Viewbotting is not the same
as in viewbotting is not um viewing is actually defrauding Twitch,
right? And this this act would not be defrauding Twitch. Twitch
is getting less eyes on their advertisements because of viewbotting.
That is like a a tangible harm that I would be upset about with
with this. But to him, I feel like he would view bot because
he doesn't care about lying to make himself look better. He has
built a reputation for himself that is bigger than he actually
is. And he probably has to keep trying to maintain that and he's
willing to do uh like deceptive and deceptive and I don't know
uh false practices to keep that going. That's I think he's shown
that and once you cross that line I don't know where you I don't
know if you come back from that right like my ego is too big
now to go backwards once you've started like buying out to to
like make yourself look bigger >> an argument that would
apply to services particularly services that were fraudulent
or misleading but beyond that there's California business code
17500 which leads to false or misleading statements or false
or misleading advertisement and this could be perceived as hey
falsely advertising that you're number one on the hype train,
that you're this hype train leader, that you're this person that
needs to be donated to keep this thing going to breach all these
levels when really most of those levels or maybe a lot of those
levels, some of those levels were just artificially inflated
by either Pirate Softwar's mod or the sock puppet accounts. I
mean, who knows? We don't really have a full track. >> His
viewership is way down the last week. He didn't break 4K per
stream. Yeah, I know. >> On that uh yet. And beyond that,
there's the unfair competition law. This one I think is pretty
juicy because this one would even allow other creators the potential
to say, "Hey, this is unfair competition. You're allowing these
people." He's lost all credibility and being credible is his
entire brand. So now we get to stomp on the flaming corpse of
his channel. Get him, boys. Is it one of those delicious moral
treats? Chinese agent, right? The Huxley line. Yes, we get to
hate. We're all morally justified in hating this man now. Get
them. Which, hey, over the WoW stuff, you want to around with
hardcore characters in World of Warcraft, I get it. Okay, that
get him for that. But this one, this one seems like we're just
trying to we're just trying to ruin this guy now. We're really
we're really trying to just destroy this guy. Little lynching
is a treat is always nice, isn't it? >> Their numbers and
get this hype train going on, get featured on the front page,
get highlighted, get hyped up, you know, by all of the platform
and by the, you know, CEO himself, all this sort of good stuff.
And that is unfair competition. That's giving them an unfair
edge because they're doing things that are violating the toos
freely. And hey, if you don't enforce this Twitch, if you don't
do anything Twitch, this is a problem. Now, beyond that, there
are other issues um other than him losing subs. And of course,
once again, him losing subs just adds the potential of people
that might sue. But beyond that, there's advertisers. Advertisers
might feel like they were defrauded. they might feel angry because
they're saying, "Hey, we're running ads and they're supposed
to be on the top channels." But if he's falsely inflating his
numbers and he's being falsely promoted, well, maybe we're not
really getting the value we thought we were getting. We thought
we were getting a value. >> I don't understand. Unless
you had proof of view botting. Hello. >> What's up? >> I
was going to say, yeah, this doesn't make any sense. >> Oh,
okay. Okay. Yeah. Unless you prove him viewing, this shouldn't
be any issue with the advertisers. In fact, like they're not
I mean unless you want to say the second the the alt account
is like them viewbotting. >> I have no idea. Um okay. Yeah.
>> Someone who's number one in the hype trains who is leading
in this pack of hype trains and we're not getting that value.
And even if they don't have a claim, they might >> uh I
don't So this is stupid. I don't I don't think Twitch Wait, does
Twitch have the ability to like advertise on I thought they didn't
have targeted advertising at all. I thought there was literally
no targeted advertising on Twitch whatsoever.
>> Express their anger. They might want they might refuse
to advertise. Beyond that, this could open the flawed fraud gates.
If Twitch does not crack down on this, does not issue some punishment,
some correction, well, others might say, "Well, I can do that,
too." And then everybody is going and committing this deception
which would just open up Twitch as a really really poor perceived
platform where everyone is essentially essentially artificially
boosting their own numbers which once again goes towards Twitch's
impotent image. Twitch is something that I've Twitch is a platform
that I've talked about a lot because they failed to enforce their
own rules evenly, fairly, and justly. And if you have terms of
service and you never enforce them, well, that's not a good look
for your platform as a whole. And that's why other platforms
are rising. Even platforms like Kick are passing Twitch in many
metrics because of their poor image. And other platforms like
YouTube look at that and say, "Hey, we're going to stay away
from those sort of images that that sort of image and enforce
our rules." So, this is a really bad look for Twitch. It does
not look good for Pirate Software and is likely to continue his
downward slide. But let me know what you guys think in the >> Uh
I think Supreme and I came to a pretty like healthy understanding
on this geeked out. I think um uh if you get to this part of
the the VOD, I think we came to a reasonable understanding. Like
there are worries to pulling back the US's power projection.
That could be an issue. That would be like probably my only concern
with Assad is that he would immediately want to pull back the
US on a whole bunch of things and he would have no concern for
like the actual like actual power projection, actual, you know,
soft power. But that was the primary concern with Trump and it
seems like whatever deep state is there almost certainly won,
right? And I believe that I believe that Hassan is like a better
person than Trump and he could be swayed. But hey,
>> and I'll catch you on the >> Are you guys enjoying
the stream today? >> Wow. Thank you. Okay, so we had these
two things. Yeah, man. I again I'm just going to go with I think
I'm going to go with the hardcore take of lying is bad and lying
to build yourself up as something you're not is even worse. And
that is a slippery slope that you will never recover from. Your
ego will never recover from, hey, I'm like this. I I think it's
over for Pirate Software because now he's like a 4,000
He's like a 4,000 view streamer or something. And I don't think
he'll ever recover from that. I think he's going to keep spiraling
downwards because he's going to be bitter about it. It's going
to destroy him, right? And all of this stuff like buying the
hype train. I think that all goes to making yourself seem bigger
than you are. And that's like really dangerous in a game where
like clout and where it's like all about clout and your ego will
get the better of you and his ego's gotten the better of him.
I don't know. I'm trying to I'm trying to express this the right
way. I've thought about this before. I'm not saying it quite
correctly, but I think we all can kind of see. People see concurrent
viewers and they don't realize viewers die and move on. Viewers
die and move on. Wow. Viewers never die. Okay. My enigmas
never age and never die. Okay. Anyway. Oh, true. Ciphy. Yes.
It's like growing can be important. Yeah, growing can be important.
That's true. All right. Where are we where are we going next?
I think did Quinn did Quinn get to something after this would
be the question. Did chats chat messages? Nothing important.
Okay. Well, let's watch uh let's watch these clips really quickly.
I don't even know if we're going to do more on this or not. Oh,
Pirate Software tweeted his own stuff out. Okay. Pirate Software
decided to do uh two responses that we should check out. These
are the same Twitter response. Hold on. Oh, these are the same
Twitter responses. Fine. I think this is probably the other one.
So, it turns out that Pirate Software got his moderators to keep
his hype train going by having them gift subs and gift bits when
he broke the hype train record. Cool. Nope. Kronos used his own
money to do this and asked if it was okay to do so. He wasn't
paid for this or told to do it either. He's a grown ass man and
can spend his money in whatever way he chooses. You can hate
me all you like, but going after my staff is to your behavior.
Why do I feel like I know this guy? Feel like this guy's commented
on my before for some reason. So QQ, did you did the 82% apply
to your perspective instead of Kronos's in this conversation?
Then confused by the wording. If not, this is something I talk
about with the community all the time. If you purchase 25,000
bits, around 80% 82% of your purchase ends up making it to the
streamer and as such pushes the hype train more. It's not secret
info. It's basic math. He wanted to push the train, so I let
him know as I always let everyone know the best way to do so.
At the end of the day, it's his money. Nobody was told to do
anything, and he's his own man and can do what he wants. Okay,
we'll see what Harful Opinions actually says here. But I think
I don't think I have any problem with that. It's basically just
doing deceptive things to to make yourself seem bigger and break
a record. Yes. This that last part is actually partly why it's
weird. He asked permission and you in return asked him uh to
let you know if he does. When the chunk when that chunk of the
conversation becomes public knowledge, it creates an appearance
of impropriety. I don't believe you don't understand this. It's
very easy to infer. I'm reading harmful opinions here because
usually he's got uh decent takes and drama. So, we'll see. The
gay the gay joker. Yes. The gay riddler. The gay Riddler. That's
what he is. Yes. It's very easy to infer an end from what's being
shown here for the very reason you just outlined. This is not
normal behavior. Sorry to multiweet, but note as well that you
appear to have given him conditional permission per his screenshot.
Meaning your tweets here about him being a grownass man. Free
to do as he wishes. Can be seen as a lie about your perspective
on the matter. Keep talking though. It Okay. Okay. It's Dude,
it's like it's right on the line, right? Big stinker. Okay. It
is. It is right on the line. I man should we check out harmful
opinions video on this harmful opinions YouTube maybe he'd have
maybe he'd have some uh good takes here. He usually does like
pretty thoughtful analysis of these things. So I'd be interested
to see it. Nothing's adding >> Long story short, >> only
12 minutes. Let's check it out. >> Some funny business
from back in July has been noticed and spread far and wide in
videos like this one by Quinio. Odds are that you know what's
up. But for future viewers and people who are not in the loop,
Pirate Software was trying to break his Twitch hype train record,
which is Twitch's gamification of onplatform donations, wherein
a hype train is leveled up if people donate enough using subs
or bits, but it's on a timer and you need more and more to progress.
If that timer runs out, I think I predict is just going to be,
you know, that you're that you're like that one that you're going
for a record and so you're falsely breaking that record by by
encouraging your mods to donate, right? or that like at least
there is an appearance of impropriety there and that man it's
like if we could see all of the DMs if somehow all of the DMs
got leaked at the same time you could almost exonerate Pirate
Software but now because only select DMs leaked and they're so
they look like so weird people will just be able to run with
their own narratives right even if Kronos comes out and says
oh yeah actually like I I I totally did this all by myself by
the way I do believe we have Kronos VODs do we not does anybody
know where the Kronos VODs are because I believe Kronos went
live and talked about this himself. self from his perspective.
So, I'd maybe check that out if if anybody has a link to those.
>> Without you, you go back to zero. It came to light as
a result of leaked Discord DMs that Pirate Software's lead mod
and legal bully, Kronos, had in at least one instance saved the
hype train with contributions from an alt account, obscuring
from the casual viewer that this FOMO moment was being perpetuated
by someone on Pyro Software's payroll. I didn't originally plan
on making a video regarding this because I didn't have anything
to add. I think it's pretty open and shut morally disgusting.
Hype trains themselves as a concept are already quite grotesque
and as a streamer to have any see this is the thing is harmful
opinions is like like a lawful good paladin type guy on the internet
like he he's like no no these are pure there here there's a bunch
of downsides. So yeah, he's going to he probably at like a moral
level thinks like um like streaming is bad in a lot of ways.
Like literally developing any kind of relationship with an audience
where you have a back and forth, right? Like that is pro he probably
believes all of those things are bad. Like there's probably so
many things he believes are bad here stacked up that this I don't
even know is this even going to comp like be much >> involvement.
Extending a hype train whilst deliberately obscuring your involvement
such that some viewers might be enticed to donate more under
the belief that something organic is happening is something I
personally wouldn't be able to live with doing. That ain't a
video though. >> I wouldn't be able to live.
I think it's a I think it's a bit far but okay. >> I can't
just talk about that for 8 minutes or more. What is worthy of
a video though is the pitch black vortex of deception that has
been spewed as a result of this information coming out.
So he's not even he's not going in even on the actual hype train
like fraud. He's going to go in on their explanations for it.
Okay. Oh, let's go. Let's go. I do I watch this guy's stream
sometimes. I think I caught him the first time cuz Chud raided
him and then I followed him on Twitch and then just if I ever
see him streaming, I'll watch. I like his videos more than his
stream. His videos are like this. >> His videos are like
perfect for me because to be honest, a lot of people yap about
nothing. I don't think this guy yaps about nothing. Like he he
honestly like lays out his thoughts quite well and he just like
is it's very uh compressed. Like it's compressed information,
compressed arguments. I I do like that he actually he just gets
to the point. He will, you might consider it yapping for him
to talk about his moral positions, but they're relevant to like
his um to his his overall opinion. And yes, it's always it's
always concise. He keeps it like as concise as >> We already
knew that Kronos is a an evil freak from his >> Jesus.
Damn interactions with private parts regarding pirate software's
blatantly unlawful DMCA takedown claim. But in this particular
>> Oh, actually true though, right? when Kronos was helping
him with the DMCA stuff with the with the Pvt parts guy. Pvt
I think it's private parts, right? That guy who makes the game
>> instead of drama >> word you're looking for is
succinct.
Um I don't know if succinct is the right word either. I think
I think concise is more it. Succinct implies like a a crispness.
I think sometimes this guy is like actually quite blunt in a
way that doesn't feel well put together. But I still like it.
>> He has done something uniquely terrible that I haven't
seen anyone pick up on. The defense against his contribution
to his boss's hype train being any form of questionable collusion
is that donators to the previous hype train record attempt the
year before were being harassed. This is also the explanation.
Oh, see I said I said personally I was like, "Hey, what if this
guy's getting made fun of for being a pay? Is that like So if
he hadn't told Pirate Software this, if there wasn't the DMs
and he hadn't told Pirate Software and he had decided on his
own, I'm going to be a pay peg under an alt because I don't want
to get mocked, I would understand that. I would actually get
it. Okay, hold on. I got to give me two seconds. I'll be right
back. I'm pulling this back. I got to use the bathroom. I just
had a bunch of caffeine. Got to use >> What is worthy of
a video, though, is the pitch black vortex of deception that
has been spewed as a result of this information coming out. We
already knew that Kronos is an evil freak from his interactions
with Private Parts regarding Pirate Software's blatantly unlawful
DMCA takedown claim. But in this particular episode of drama,
he has done something uniquely terrible that I haven't seen anyone
pick up on. The defense against his contribution to his boss's
hype train being any form of questionable collusion is that donators
to the previous hype train record attempt the year before were
being harassed. This is also the explanation for why the VOD
was removed. And Krono says that he himself had been messaged.
This makes some kind of sense. If you want to give gift subs
anonymously, there's a checkbox for that. But if you want to
give bits, you need an alt account to hide your identity because
you can't give bits anonymously due to there being a message
attached. Twitch decided you have to use your identity so that
if you say something abusive, the streamer can ban you. There
is some
>> Oh, hello. I'm back. Okay, interesting.
to the idea that you need to use an alt account to hide your
identity if you are a regular viewer. For someone who is a mod
of this man with thousands of viewers who has already donated
a ton under his standard alias though, the idea that this provides
any kind of mitigation is ludicrous. And it only gets worse because
if we believe Kronos's explanation, he has deliberately endangered
other people. In the leaked DMs from the deleted Pyrosopher stream,
Kronos outs his alt as serendipitous bean. YouTuber Quinthio
got his hands on the deleted viant and has shown us the messages
associated with serendipitous beans bit donations. >> Serendipitous
Bean with 25,000 bits said, "My favorite ferret is beef because
wh
the beef." >> So that was the first one sent from Kronos
and this is the second one. >> Serendipitous Bean with
50,000 bits said IRL friend of Kronos and excited that they are
now free from corporate. >> I know. >> Love your
stream and what you do for people here. There aren't many cool
or supportive streamers left once they >> Dude,
maybe the most offensive thing is the glaze message right here.
Okay, maybe that is actually the most offensive thing. Dude,
it's so awesome that you're just like such a nice person and
you know I love you and Kronos loves you too. You really help
Kronos. Thanks, >> They get big like this, stay cool, bud,
and tell Kronos that Ben sends their >> Two things to note.
That's $750.
If you think ever in your life for a single moment about giving
that much money to your boss, please realize first that rope
is far cheaper. And secondly, hi. From this alt account he made
to protect himself from getting messages, he made a donation
naming himself. And not only that, if donators are a target,
he made anyone who could be perceived to be Kronos's friend a
target. He made anyone called Ben. Okay, this is a total this
is you're going way nutty with that
>> Think about the bends, man. Come on. >> The internet
skitsos could figure out might have something to do with Kronos.
A target. This alone is utterly unethical. You do not >> dude.
I is a lie. >> Not protect yourself by painting targets
on other people's backs. You just >> the argument here
is oh if you were really scared then you basically took anybody
who could be considered a Ben who's friends with Kronos and made
them a target or something. It's like dude like I think the harassment
he's trying to avoid is not that bad. I don't know. I think I
think this is probably this seems too far to me. >> Disgusting
worm croner. >> A little too far. Hold on. I'll pull it
back. I'll see. Maybe he's got way better. I understand that
he like technically is sort of he gave a name and that could
put people in a different direction, but like man, I think the
harassment he's trying to avoid is probably something that like
isn't going to go at it like another Ben. I don't n maybe maybe
it is that bad. I don't know. I'm trying to think of like I can't
think of like internet skits who would go and find like every
Ben that's ever been attached to Kronos in some way and like
look for that person to mock them. I'm guessing that the actual
hate goes to like the p the the accounts that would be associated
with that account, right? That like Kronos is uniquely easy to
target because he's Kronos. He's known in the community. So when
he donates, he could get mocked and made fun of, right? And and
like saying your name's Ben, but it's not tied to anything and
there's no serendipitous being like Twitter or Discord account
that they could go and with, right? I think they would just give
up. Like I I don't think there's like a lot of with people beyond
it's probably just uniquely easy to with Kronos because he is
like a big part of that community >> is utterly unethical.
You do not protect yourself by painting targets on other people's
backs. You disgusting
worm, Kronos. Luckily, this is only the case if I believe his
blatant lie. There is zero credibility carried by his claim.
People do not try to protect their identity to avoid messages
by using an alt account to make a donation and naming themselves
in the associated message. Speaking of zero credibility,
>> I don't know. Maybe >> I'm guessing that the people
who get harassed is probably people looking at like a leaderboard
after like if they publish a leaderboard and maybe Kronos just
didn't want to be number one in that leaderboard this time. >> Go
for it. >> Maybe you can say that's unethical cuz then
somebody else is number one who's going to get harassed. >> What
has to say about all this? Oh, look. A massive stack of insane
lies. I mean, look at this. Read it. Actually, just read it.
Oh, wait. Okay. Kronos used his own money to do this and asked
if it was okay to do so. Kronos is a grownass man and can spend
his money in whatever way he chooses. Correct. So, why the hell
was he asking you permission? Yes, you've just explained. You've
you've made this video for me. That is why it's suspicious. He
could have just given you money. He would have been a massive
for donating to his boss, but fine. The question at hand is why
did he coordinate with you? And additionally, Kronos provided
more messages than were in the leak when he asked about Wait,
why why is he why is he ask why would he do this? Why why would
Kronos do this? Why would Kronos come out and say, "Look, I asked
him permission, guys." Why? Why the would he do that? Bro, these
people are like I transparency, I guess, but why the would you
come out and literally say, "Oh, no, guys. I I asked for his
permission." Okay, so >> donating you gave conditional
permission when he >> Okay, so I've already dropped 100
tier ones, so like oneird of last year. But as I said when we
discussed all those weirdest messages sent around the community
in January, I'm going to switch to my alt in case I want to drop
more. If I do drop more, I'll be dropping them at the end of
the level timer, the 30 secondond mark, for example, because
the community always tries to last second it, and Twitch is lagging
hard, so that's a recipe for disaster. Out of interest for when
I stream in May, what's the best way for people to take part
in hype trains? Oh, wait. Why? Hold on. Hold on. The message
is edited, too, cuz Sorry. He's not asking for permission to
do this, right? He's not asking for permission at all here. He's
saying, "I'm going to do this. If I drop more, I'll do it from
an alt cuz I don't want to be getting weird. Why is that a conditional?
Pirate software is saying if it's about to lose. Sure. But the
the message here looks weird given that this one's edited, right?
Out of interest for when I stream in May. What's the best way
for people Dude? Okay, that looks sketchy though. I'm going to
change this. Oh, that looks pretty sketchy. Can we see when that
was edited? I want to know that was edited before. Yeah, I want
to know when that was edited. I want him to mouse over, but I
Dude, do you even trust him at this point? It's about to lose.
Sure, dude. Yeah. I don't know the >> You asked about donating.
You gave conditional permission. Far from Kronos being a grownass
man who can do what he wants. You >> I would say a non-response
by pirate following an edit. Well, I mean, Pirate could just
not be paying attention cuz Pirate could be Pirate's live, right?
I I misread messages fairly often actually when people message
me during my live stream. If I'm like busy doing something and
somebody asks me and I just try to give a quick reply, I will
misread that [__] sometimes, right? Trying to like
get a response out without like losing my focus on whatever stream,
whatever's going on on stream. So, I totally understand the bad
response, but just the edit there makes me think, no, no, no.
It was like, hey, can I keep the hype? Should I keep the hype
train going? Would it be good if I did this or something? I don't
know. >> I I hope Harmful explains that he just doesn't
believe that message, though, because it's not Kronos asking
for permission. He's saying I'm going to donate. If I donate
um what's the what? Hold on. If I donate like Did I go the wrong
way here? I'm missing that. >> It's like if I donate, what's
the best way to do it? Right here. Sorry. Less than 5 seconds.
Like he says if I donate more, I'm going to do it late so the
community doesn't give or I'm going to do it before it gets too
late because it's going to up. Um yeah, the question is not about
>> asked about donating. You gave conditional permission.
Far from Kronos being a grownass man who can do what he wants.
You actually technically told him no
unless unless the train is about to die. I've heard that you
have trouble
no not based on those messages. I feel like I feel like he thought
Kronos was asking for permission and he was like, "Yeah, yeah,
do it if it's about to die, Gus." Right. But I don't think Kronos
was doing that. I think Kronos, at least in those messages as
they're edited, if you read them without thinking that they got
edited to like something less offensive, it seems like Kronos
is just saying, "If I donate more, I'll do it to keep the hype
train going." And then Pirates Software goes, "Yeah, if it's
about to die, go ahead." Standing if statements. But come on,
man. And as Pirate Software pointed out himself, why would that
be any of his business? We know from the leak that he specifically
asked to be made aware. Why would he need to know? The only answer
I can think of as a streamer myself putting myself in his shoes
is if I was going to reimburse that person, why else would I
be so intent on knowing the specifics? >> Man, oh, he's
making leaps. This guy, this guy's like Superman. Okay, leaps
and bounds. >> I mean, realistically, I'd say don't. That's
weird. I'm paying you. But if I was being asked permission, I
was going to okay it and that was how things worked between me
and this guy. What other reason would there be? I genuinely cannot
come up with another answer that isn't deranged. Someone asked
Byro Software about the discussion of best percentage return
that occurred in the leaks. P explains that people often ask
which option ends up with the highest percentage reaching the
stream. >> This was my assumption before I saw his response
was that I think probably he's just telling people how to best
convert like into hype train duration or or
>> I believe it. I get that question all the time. He says
it's not secret info. It's basic math. Correct. So why did Kronos
need to ask you? In fact, we know for certain that the assertion
Kronos was merely asking which method is optimal is untrue. Not
only that, but Pyrus says it's basic maths. But in the leak,
we can see that he didn't know. You tell everyone this, huh?
Pyro Software. You tell everyone I don't know. You were paid
to be a social engineer. You're the worst liar I've seen in my
life. Back to the optimization lie. Kronos offered to do 40 tier
threes on an alt bits instead or both if he was merely seeking
the optimal method and one of them would have a greater return.
>> This is better that when you read it this way. This
is much better, right? That like and it makes that edit seem
even more suspicious to me, doesn't it? I feel like it makes
that edit seem even weirder to me that he's like, "Oh, well,
I can do this from an alt or can do bits instead or both." Did
50k bits at 20 seconds left. He's like updating him on this.
I think this is But I don't I don't necessarily think Pirate
Software is actually um I don't think he's even reimbursing the
guy to tell you the truth. I think this guy is just like trying
to This guy is just trying to like let him know that I'm helping.
I'm helping I'm helping. Turn percentage. Why would he ever offer
to do both? Because he offered to do both. It cannot be true
that he was merely asking which method is optimal. Why someone
might do both though is to make it look a bit more natural. Like
the person donating doesn't know these things and it's just >> time
to end stream. Timer ran down. I'll probably end after the pirate
software stuff. Unless that one guy actually managed to join
the discord. I don't think he did though. >> He's the last
cause. >> I dude he just I I unbanned some guy. I struggled
to think what to talk about next cuz this is a crazy web of After
this was brought to light. Kronos posted some of the messages
prior to the leak. I saw a glaring issue instantly. Have you
spotted it? 3 2 1. This little bad boy right here. Luckily, Discord
will tell you when that edit occurred if you hover it with your
mouse. So, I immediately asked him to make a little clip. It
has now been multiple days, and I believe Quinio told me in my
live stream chat that he's asked directly. In his latest upload,
Quinio said this as well. Matter of fact, even with the previous
messages that Kronos showed, one of which is edited, and apparently
he is just not available right now, but in the next few days,
I should be able to see when he edited that message. Yeah, I'll
show you that. Just the give me a week. No, I'm not willing to
be quite this charitable. This is a literally less than 60 seconds
endeavor. And the edited message itself is incredibly suspicious
to me cuz remember
>> I just had to look at Discord. Quinio told me in my
life
>> to one this little bad boy right here. >> Oh,
thank God. Yes. Okay, we're getting here. Okay, we're good. >> Will
tell you when that edit occurred if you hover it with your mouse.
So, I immediately asked him to make a little clip. It has now
been multiple days and I believe Quinio told me in my live stream
chat that he's asked directly in his latest upload. Quinio said
this as well. Matter of fact, even with the previous messages
that Kronos showed, one of which is edited, and apparently >> that
edit looks so not available right now, but in the next few days,
I should be able to see when he edited that message. Yeah, I'll
show you that. Just the give me a week. No, I'm not willing to
be quite this charitable. This is a literally less than 60 seconds
endeavor. And the edited message itself is incredibly suspicious
to me cuz remember, this is the only corroborating evidence of
his public claim that the reason for using an alt was protecting
his identity we've been given. and it's an edited Discord message.
Further to that, there's another issue I have with the content
of the message. One way people lie is they recontextualize
>> What we propose to do is not to control content, but
to create context. >> What we we saw in the leak with >> So
that starts to explain why there's like more of this explanation
here, right? When he says, "Oh, what's the best way to do this,
you know, in future bits is going is the best way to do it due
to the return if you need to save it? If you need to save it,
if you need to save it. If you need to save the hype train. What
it's see this is Oh,
thank god the gay Riddler was was all in on this because now
I'm seeing it. Okay, I'm seeing it a little more. This is going
to be the best way to do it due to the return if you need to
save it. If you need to save the hype train, right? If you need
to last minute save the hype train, the best way to do it is
bits. Bits rather than tier 3es. So, it seems like probably I
think these two had an agreement that you'll save the hype train,
right? If it's if it's breaking down, you'll save the hype train.
And that probably leads you to believe that there probably is
some reimbursement deal here, right? Like, hey, I will reimburse
you for this because you're going to keep the hype train going
to make sure we get the record. And I've decided that I'll take
whatever financial burden that requires >> was obviously
a discussion about the best way to save Pyro Software's hype
train should it timing out. Kronos then decided to provide us
without timestamp an edited message where he asked at the end
out of interest for when I stream in May, what's the best way
for people to take part? >> That's so weird. It's such
a weird message given the >> hype trains. To me, this reads
as a clumsy attempt to recontextualize and reframe their discussion
as being, >> hey, I figured that out right away and I was
like, oh, he's got to talk about that, right? >> Generically
about which method is best. I just didn't follow this that closely
when it came out because it seemed really gay to me. Like, but
I see exactly what he's saying. Like, the the overall thing this
is, but like the fact that they go and lie to like make this
seem different than it was is also weird. Very weird. But hype
trains instead of master, how can I serve you? Which it obviously
was. And Pirate Software believes it was. As he said, he saw
that as Kronos asking permission to give him money. Speaking
of things that Pyrus Software said in response to this, let's
go over a couple more. You can hate me all you like, but going
after my staff is behavior. You mean specifically Kronos? I can't
name a single other member of your staff, and people's interest
in him is specifically for his behavior, such as this. And before
when he bullied private parts. Your staff member isn't just some
guy. As far as >> I didn't I didn't say anything there.
I'm not muted or anything. I was just like, yeah, I I think this
also goes to Pirate Software's whole thing where like he tries
to do the the oh, they want to get to you, but they have to go
through me thing where he's like, I'm the heroic him, Teone,
all of these people do this thing, right? Where it's like, oh
yeah, well, I'm protecting I'm protecting this guy, right? They
try to they try to moralize like bullying um the people around
him and and they try to make it seem like, oh, all these people
are on Hinge. They're not just going after me. They're going
after my staff. Can you believe it? You believe that? >> Concerned.
He's a public figure. He is a streamer partnered with Twitch
whose VODs have far over 10 times the reach of my own. The >> Kronos
is a big streamer. What the 11,000 views? What? Bro, Kronos gets
a ton of views. What the hell? >> Partnered with Twitch,
whose VODs have far over 10 times the reach of my own. The they're
going after my staff line is incredibly deceptive. You mean the
Ethan Klein thing? Uh, only for people obsessed with Ethan like
you, Queenman. Only for self-hating anti-Semitic Jews. Okay.
Then we could say it's the Ethan Klein thing. For me, it's like
the techone
pirate software thing. Okay. That level of narcissism. >> He
is not just a humble moderator. >> Yeah. And oh, did it
sound like I was making a point there? I was just saying.
>> He is an influencer in his own right. If he's not, then
I'm certainly not. And no one can say anything about me. Another
thing Pyro said about this, >> dude. Hold on, hold on,
hold on, Queman. That's the That's my favorite thing. It's like
uh Oh, I I just want to I wanted to point this out. I would have
like I would have asked for your opinion on this. I didn't see
your coverage. Maybe I'll check it out at some point later. But
just the the Destiny tweet the um the Destiny Pisco thing. I
don't understand. Even if Okay, let me pull this Let me pull
this thread up. If you're watching, I'll do this right now. Even
if you go to the very end of this, right? Where's this stupid
line? Where's the Right here. I'd vote for the guy who supported
January 6th versus the guy who supported October 7th. Even if
Assan straight up supported October 7th, exactly how it happened.
Even if we granted that, this is the guy who like did 9/11 on
the soul of your country on like the process of democracy in
your country. How do you compare that to the guy who had no part
in architecting October 7th, right? Trump architected and created
January 6th. It's like saying like you could compare if you wanted
to say, okay, Trump versus Bin Laden, then I go Trump then maybe.
Okay. Yes. But but literally the people who who responded to
me when I mocked this are like, you're being so disingenuous.
It's obvious what Destiny means here. Like Dared Kelly or Oh
my god. Okay. I just want to vent about that real quick. >> This
incident was that Kronos wasn't paid for this or told to do it
either. Both of these claims are false. Well, that or other things
he said are lies. Before the day of the Giga Train, he announced
that 50% of the income from it will be paid to mods as a bonus.
So, if that's true, yes, you did literally pay him for it, either
in the most way possible where he got a percentage back or perhaps
you reimbured him further than that. >> What Destiny means
here is Pisco, please off to a grave so I don't have you nuking
my career like this. It's literally like, I'm going to lie about
you guys. I'm going to do anything deceptive I possibly can to
with you guys until you leave me alone and let me just have my
my space and my money with all of you, okay? I'll lie about all
of you. I'll say whatever I have to to make you look bad, okay?
It's it's just transparent. Now, don't even try. Or >> it's
all as transparent as I'll stop doxing you when you stop denying
that this dox is you. >> Think for a second about trying
to say I tried to keep track of his donations so that I could
actually deduct that from what I was going to pay him as a bonus
so it didn't go back to him and didn't look sus. If that were
the case, you would have just said it by now. The reason you
were so intent on knowing specifics is something else. What's
the real reason, Jason? I would love to hear. And fair warning,
I was just curious. isn't going to cut it. His claim that he
didn't ask for him to do it is obviously a liebo omission. He
was asked permission and said if it's about to lose sure publicly
pirate software is only telling >> he wasn't I'll say with
the edited message he wasn't asked permission but or he wasn't
asking for permission but I do believe he was before the edit
actually asking for permission because that makes everything
every part of those DMs make way more sense right if he was asking
for permission if they did have some agreement to keep the sub
the subathon going right in fact like the most likely scenario
if I'm fabricating scenarios in my head is like they probably
had some agreement over how far Kronos would go to keep it going
and then they'd probably gone past that and he was like, "Hey,
I'm ready to like do more, so let me know." >> That's that
he was asked and that he didn't tell Kronos to do it. I think
it's incredibly significant that when asked permission, he gave
it conditionally. I didn't tell him to do it. He just asked if
he could and I said, "Yeah, do it if we're about to lose." I
didn't tell him to do it. Off, dude. To cap this off, people
are trying to make this into something really big. Did Pirate
Software break the law? Did he break Twitch to? I don't really
care. Regardless of consequences, what I've seen is enough. You
simply do not manipulate people like this. It's like making a
Kickstarter when you have the plan to anonymously top it off.
You are deliberately warping people's perception of what's being
contributed to to get their money. Go ahead and beg. Go ahead
and add subs as yourself. This weird behind the curtain collusion
between two people who remember both have a financial interest
in the success of this hype train. No, you do not do this. don't
give a [__] if it's legally fraud or not or anything
like this. In my eyes, you're a scammer. You and your little
flying monkey Kronos. If you are topping off something like a
hype train or a Kickstarter, something timed that needs to hit
a target to continue or be complete and you are set to benefit
from those funds, everyone watching should know that has happened.
It is wrong.
>> Oh, but they did know. They did know that he was set
to benefit from those funds, right? Like I believe this was I
believe these screenshots were put out before, right? Like I
believe he's he announced this before if I'm not mistaken that
hey we're we're going to give everybody a little more money out
of this. Where's these where are these screenshots? One second.
Yeah, March 29th, right? March 29th is the first one. So like
I think that was known. If Kronos had just not used the alt,
this is probably all fine. Like I I I don't know if there's that.
>> Utterly unethical to deny them that information. If
it is not safe for you to do that, then you don't do it. You
let the hype train die and you get a bit less of a bonus. That
is not a justification to deceive the masses for your financial
benefit. It is that >> Hold on. There's no way he didn't
miss that, did he? Let me see here. I don't know if I was following
this quite so closely right at the end. Can I Dude, what the
>> You are deliberately warping off people that he was
asked and that he didn't tell Kronos to do it. I think it's incredibly
significant that when asked permission, he gave it from it >> will
be paid to mods as a bonus. So if that's true, yes, you did literally
pay him for it. Either in the most way possible, we got a percentage
back or perhaps you reimbured him further than that. Now, don't
even try or think for a second about trying to say I tried to
keep track of his donations so that I could actually deduct that
from where I was. Jason, I would love to hear. And fair warning,
I was just curious isn't going to cut it. His claim that he didn't
ask her to do it is obviously a lie by omission. He was asked
permission and said that if it's about to lose, sure, publicly
harness that he was asked and that he didn't tell to do it. I
think it's incredibly significant that when asked permission,
he gave it conditionally. I didn't tell him to do it. He actually
could. I said >> again, given the I think you have to point
out the I didn't tell it off, dude. Cap this off. People are
trying to make this into something really big. Did pirates offer
break the law? Did he break Twitch to? I don't really care. Regardless
of consequences, what I've seen is enough. You simply do not
manipulate people like this. It's like making a Kickstarter when
you have the plan to anonymously top it off. You are deliberately
warping people's perception of what's being contributed to to
get their money. Go ahead and beg. Go ahead and add subs as yourself.
this weird behind the curtain collusion between two people who
remember both have a financial interest in the success of this
hype train. No, you do not do this. Don't give a [__]
if it's legally fraud or not or anything like this. In my eyes,
you're a scammer. You and your little flying monkey Kronos. If
you are topping off something like a hype train or a Kickstarter,
something timed that needs to hit a target to continue or be
complete and you are set to benefit from those funds, everyone
watching should know that has happened. It is >> okay.
So, always incorrect to donate via somebody else. If you donate
transparently through yourself to keep it going, that's fine.
I don't know if you get a hype train record if you were to carry
it all yourself. I thought I thought maybe he was talking about
the uh the 50% bonus that that he wasn't sure if um if that was
just immoral, utterly unethical to deny them that information.
If it is not safe for you to do that, then you don't do it. You
let the hype train die and you get a bit less of a bonus. That
is not a justification to deceive the masses for your financial
benefit. It is that simple. There is no wiggling out of this.
The response being anything other than a public apology and disclosure
means you lose. Open and shut. Done. You're a wrong. You didn't
tell him to. He can do what he wants. But you knew it was happening.
You explicitly permitted it and you made no disclosure. You are
100% on the hook. Even if nothing I suspect was going on, went
on. What we know concretely for sure happened was itself wrong.
And if you don't understand why what you've done is wrong, that's
even worse. It means you're incapable of being a good person.
Long story short, >> this guy goes so hard. Holy [__]
Uh, I do broadly agree with him that like it's a deceptive behavior.
Is it like the worst thing in the world? I don't know if I like
in terms of the things you
I don't know. Probably enough to just say it was wrong and you
shouldn't do it and you should be transparent. No, no, no. I'm
like trying to think of like what I would I think it's like just
one of those things that's like kind of pathetic. Like if you
knew that he was breaking the record and that he was like advertising
this broken record as like knowing that he himself had safety
nets and people were going to top it off no matter what. Harmful
opinions is huge on consumer rights and manipulation. Yeah. Because
he came from like Gamergate, right? He was like a Gamergate commentator.
And so like that is already that's like the basis for the foundation.
That's like the foundation of him streaming, right? Was Gamergate
which is in itself like a huge consumer rights and online like
reputation manipulation thing. So sure I can see that. I think
it's wrong. It's like I would expect something like it to be
happening. So, it feels a little less wrong to me, but it probably
still needs to be called out. Glad he's like there to make the
argument, right? I I think he's like overselling it a little
bit like in terms of how bad it is, but I do respect that there's
somebody who's willing to just like make that argument as harshly
as possible to, you know, make sure everybody cuz I can't I can't
really go, "No, no, no, no. It's like not bad, right?" No, it's
lying. It's obvious lying is bad. Lying is always bad. Um,
and the the other fact that it sort of pales in most of the other
it pales in comparison to a lot of the other behaviors he's exhibited.
Pirate software that is. So like it doesn't even really contribute
to the things I feel negatively about him for like it barely
tops that off at all if but that's not really man it's interesting.
It's like it's a bad thing. It's a clearly bad thing. It's clearly
deceptive thing. It is wrong but it is also like number 11 on
all of the things that he's done. So, it's almost difficult to
add it in and and make it like a substantial part of my mental
model. Yeah. Interesting. Cool. There'll be harmful opinions.
Okay,
that's it for the stream tonight. I'm out of here. Thank you
very much for being here tonight, guys. This is a fun stream.
I think that Oh, tonight was late, so the the all the prices
were like higher or whatever. I was charging more for time. I
just I didn't want to go that late tonight. It was a late start,
so I didn't want to go that late. All right. Thank you guys very
much for being here. Enjoyed it. The top of the pyramid is still
him not clicking on his mana items. Actual baffling gameplay.
True. Yes. Yes. Buying an award is industry plant behavior. And
he is an industry plant. This is true. This is true. All right.
W stream guys. Thank you very much for being here. Love you all.
I'm out. Okay. Have a good night. Bye-bye for now.